My name, my last name is Odenkirk and we have a we have a genetic deep predisposition to lecturing people.
我的名字是奥登柯克，我们有一种天生的说教倾向。
It's so stupid.
真是太蠢了。
All my brothers do it.
我所有的兄弟都这样做。
It's why you were perfect as Arthur.
这就是为什么你作为亚瑟是完美的。
What the fuck is that?
那是什么鬼？
in New York City.
在纽约市。
Hello and welcome to another episode of How We Made Your Mother.
大家好，欢迎收看《我们如何成就了你的母亲》的另一集。
I'm your host, Josh Radner.
我是你们的主持人乔什·拉德纳。
I am here with my co-host, Craig Thomas.
我和我的搭档主持人克雷格·托马斯一起在这里。
Hey, Craig.
嘿，克雷格。
I'm proud to be your amopostrophe co-host, my co-host.
我很自豪能成为你们的反义词共同主持人，我的共同主持人。
That's a Scottish.
那是苏格兰人。
It's how you say it as a Scottish.
作为一个苏格兰人，你就是这么说的。
So we are talking today about how I met your mother season three episodes.
所以今天我们要讨论的是《我是如何遇见你妈妈》第三季的。
Is this 15, 315, which is the time we're starting to record this?
现在是15、315吗？我们开始记录这个的时间？
at this.
在此。
And this episode is called the chain of screaming.
而这一集被称为尖叫连环。
It was written by Whom.
这是谁写的。
It was written by Carter Bayes and Craig Thomas.
它是由卡特·贝叶斯和克雷格·托马斯编写的。
Okay.
好的。
The thing about this was in the midst of shooting nine episodes in about 10 and a half weeks.
事情发生在大约十周半的时间里拍摄九集的过程中。
And it was just such a free for all.
这对所有人来说都是免费的。
It was like, I don't even know who wrote what names or scripts.
就像，我什至不知道谁写了什么名字或剧本。
It was all big guy.
都是大佬。
It was the Okay.
这是好的。
Yeah.
是的。
Um, uh, Alec, tell us when this episode aired originally on April 14th, uh, 2008.
嗯，呃，Alec，请告诉我们这一集最初于 2008 年 4 月 14 日播出的时间。
Okay.
好的。
Uh, well, we are going to have a very special guest, this episode, uh, he is the guest star from this episode.
呃,好吧,我们将会有一位非常特别的嘉宾,这一集,呃,他是这一集的客串明星。
Uh, he was already an icon and a legend when he joined us and he only became, uh, more iconic and more legendary after he was with us.
呃，当他加入我们时，他已经是一个偶像和传奇了，而在他和我们在一起之后，他才变得，呃，更具标志性和传奇性。
Although he did a bunch of episodes, right?
虽然他拍了很多集，对吧？
How many episodes did Bob do?
鲍勃拍了多少集？
We think he was in Alec to be count him was it's eight or nine total or so.
我们认为他在亚历克中算他，总共有八九个左右。
Some of them are smaller appearances.
其中一些外观较小。
But yeah, he was he we're so lucky.
但是，是的，他就是他，我们很幸运。
We got him to do this a shocking number of times.
我们让他这样做的次数令人震惊。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, our guest today is is the great Bob Oden Kirk.
好吧，我们今天的客人是伟大的鲍勃·奥登·柯克。
We're so happy to have Bob join us.
我们很高兴鲍勃加入我们。
Craig and I are going to give it a little bit about the episode before Bob hops on, but Craig, give us a little give us your armchair summary of what this episode is about.
克雷格和我将在鲍勃上台之前对这一集进行一些介绍，但是克雷格，请给我们一些关于这一集内容的扶手椅总结。
Yeah, this is this is this is the exploration of a phenomenon, the chain of screaming or perhaps it's a pyramid of screaming or maybe the circle of screaming.
是的，这就是这，这是对一种现象的探索，尖叫链，或者也许是尖叫金字塔，或者也许是尖叫圆圈。
We don't quite know.
我们不太清楚。
Just this idea of who who can you punch down upon in life and should you?
生活中你可以打谁，你应该打谁？
It's one of life's great questions, really.
这确实是人生中最伟大的问题之一。
And just this idea that Marshall has been just legitimately screamed at as an adult, which I want to talk about, and I want to ask you about and Bob about, because it's rare to get screamed at as an adult.
马歇尔作为一个成年人被合理地尖叫这个想法，我想谈谈，我想问你和鲍勃，因为作为一个成年人很少有人被尖叫。
And I like Marshall's characterization that he was just a little kid again when it happened.
我喜欢马歇尔的描述，即事情发生时他又只是个小孩子。
He immediately sent back to something.
他立刻发回了东西。
Well, we'll get there.
好吧，我们会到达那里。
But it's that exploration of, I mean, he's also exploring Marshall.
但我的意思是，他也在探索马歇尔。
Marshall has sold his soul out to go give up his dreams of being an environmental lawyer and go to this terrible corporate place where the culture is the chain of screaming and he finds himself soul searching and it's like one of those moments of what have I done?
马歇尔已经出卖了他的灵魂，放弃了成为一名环境律师的梦想，去了这个可怕的公司，那里的文化是尖叫的链条，他发现自己在进行灵魂的反省，这就像我所做的那些时刻之一？
Where am I in this life right now?
我今生在哪里？
Well speaking really quickly of happier times where there was no shouting, I just want to say that I presented Craig with an award last night.
好吧，快速地说一下没有喊叫的快乐时光，我只想说我昨晚向克雷格颁发了奖项。
Oh my god.
我的天啊。
I mean choose creativity awards, which is an incredible organization.
我的意思是选择创意奖，这是一个令人难以置信的组织。
Incredible organization that Craig's been involved with for a long time.
克雷格长期参与的令人难以置信的组织。
They gave him an award and Craig very kindly asked me to present him with this award which I did last night.
他们给了他一个奖项，克雷格非常友善地要求我向他颁发这个奖项，我昨晚就这样做了。
Jordana joined me.
乔丹娜加入了我。
Rebecca was there.
丽贝卡在那里。
You had a whole host of family members there.
你那里有很多家庭成员。
It was the best.
这是最好的。
It was an amazing night.
这是一个美妙的夜晚。
Josh, you were so I'm so grateful to you for getting up and giving me this unbelievable intro.
乔希，你真是太棒了，我非常感谢你站起来给我做了这个令人难以置信的介绍。
Here's the only problem with Josh Rander giving you an intro and then you have to go talk in front of 500 people.
这是 Josh Rander 给你做介绍之后你必须在 500 人面前演讲的唯一问题。
I was in tears as I started to give.
当我开始奉献时，我泪流满面。
I was like so fighting tears, which Jordana and one of the co-hosts, Kevin and Raina Creme, created Chews Creativity, it's an amazing organization, they bring arts and education into schools that need it here in New York City and they're expanding.
我就像在忍住眼泪，乔丹娜和联合主持人之一凯文和雷娜·克里姆创建了Chews Creativity，这是一个了不起的组织，他们将艺术和教育带入纽约市需要的学校，并且他们正在扩大规模。
They're unbelievable humans.
他们是令人难以置信的人类。
I was so honored.
我感到非常荣幸。
They had a few honorees that embody creativity somehow, and introducers were part of the equation and Josh was mine, and Jordana and Kevin both came up to me who had read Josh's remarks said, you're going to cry.
他们有一些在某种程度上体现创造力的获奖者，介绍人是等式的一部分，乔什是我的，乔丹娜和凯文都来找我，他们读了乔什的言论，说，你会哭的。
You're going to have a hard time getting your shit together after Josh's introduction.
在乔什的介绍之后，你将很难恢复正常。
And it's what happened.
这就是发生的事情。
They were right.
他们是对的。
Can I tell you that the part I cut, because it was slightly long, was about how over the years texting with you, I always think I've got a great joke.
我可以告诉你，我剪掉的部分，因为它有点长，是关于这些年来和你发短信的，我一直认为我有一个很好的笑话。
And I say a great joke, and you always say a funnier joke back to me, like it happens so consistently.
我说了一个很棒的笑话，而你总是对我说一个更好笑的笑话，就像这种情况经常发生一样。
And last night, I was like, feeling pretty good about my remarks.
昨晚，我对自己的言论感到非常满意。
And then you got up and you cried.
然后你站起来哭了。
You were so funny and moving.
你是如此有趣和感人。
And like, maybe we can find a way to talk more at length about what I said about you, which I think is worth logging into the record.
就像，也许我们可以找到一种方法来更详细地讨论我对你所说的话，我认为这值得记录下来。
But also your speech was just lovely and really about something like about the formation of an artist and a writer.
而且你的演讲也很可爱，而且确实是关于艺术家和作家的形成之类的事情。
Thank you, my friend.
谢谢你，我的朋友。
I was so nervous.
我很紧张。
It was like 500 people.
大约有 500 人。
Yeah, it was a big crowd.
是的，当时有一大群人。
It was a big crowd.
这是一大群人。
Thanks, my friend.
谢谢，我的朋友。
That was a big crowd.
那是一大群人。
Even you felt that a little bit, right?
就连你也有一点感觉吧？
Because I'm a writer.
因为我是一名作家。
I'm terrified up there.
我在上面很害怕。
But you admit that was a big one.
但你承认那是一件大事。
Well, Jordana leaned over to me and she said, she said this was a lot bigger than our wedding.
好吧，乔丹娜向我倾身，她说，她说这比我们的婚礼大得多。
You know, like there was a lot of people.
你知道，好像有很多人。
This was a crowd.
这是一群人。
You were amazing.
你太棒了。
I felt just overwhelmed with love and joy.
我感到充满了爱和喜悦。
Thank you, my friend.
谢谢你，我的朋友。
It was an incredible night.
这是一个令人难以置信的夜晚。
You're the best.
你是最棒的。
You said such nice things.
你说了这么多好话。
And you said, well, thanks for asking me.
你说，好吧，谢谢你邀请我。
Josh is such a good writer.
乔什是一位很好的作家。
Well, I got the seal of approval that mattered.
嗯，我得到了重要的批准印章。
I got the seal of approval that mattered from your daughter, Celia.
我从你的女儿西莉亚那里得到了重要的认可印章。
You got the Celia of approval, nice.
你得到了西莉亚的认可，很好。
Celia of approval.
西莉亚表示赞同。
See, that's an amazing creative spirit coming out of me.
看，这是我身上散发出的惊人的创造力。
In my shitty puns, Celia found Josh gave me his speech, the cards of his speech.
在我的双关语中，西莉亚发现乔什给了我他的演讲，他的演讲卡片。
And I was reading them like this more.
我更多地是这样读的。
I was looking at them this morning.
今天早上我正在看着他们。
And Celia came and took them and read the whole speech.
西莉亚过来接过他们并宣读了整个演讲。
And she's like, Josh is a good writer.
她说，乔什是一位好作家。
And I told Josh, this means a lot coming from Cecilia, who's a really good man.
我告诉乔什，这对塞西莉亚来说意味着很多，她是一个非常好的人。
Never has a compliment meant more than 10-year-olds.
任何赞美都不会涉及 10 岁以上的孩子。
She was like, blooping him, I'm a good writer.
她对他说，我是个好作家。
Yeah, she was, she was very much.
是的，她是，她非常。
Well, that was, that was adults, last night was adults behaving civilly.
嗯，那就是，那是大人，昨晚是大人讲文明。
This episode is- That was no screaming.
这一集是——没有尖叫。
That was a chain of loving.
那是一条爱的链条。
And this is a chain of screaming.
这是一连串的尖叫。
Today we're talking about the chain of screaming.
今天我们要说的是尖叫连环。
So what were your, I was actually, A certain episodes that in your mind, obviously many years on, they don't have icon status for whatever reason.
那么你的，我实际上是，在你看来，某些剧集，显然很多年过去了，无论出于何种原因，它们都没有偶像地位。
Maybe it's because the press hasn't written about them or they just haven't made the top 10 lists that go around every couple of years.
也许是因为媒体没有报道过他们，或者他们只是没有进入每隔几年出现一次的前十名名单。
But this episode is really funny.
但这集真的很搞笑。
It's got some huge laughs.
它有一些巨大的笑声。
I am with you.
我和你在一起。
I forgot how funny and good this episode was.
我忘记了这一集是多么有趣和精彩。
Again, because it was in this blur, we were just slapping them together in no time at all, And it just, I never processed it.
再说一次，因为它是在这种模糊中，我们只是立即将它们拍在一起，只是，我从未处理过它。
This was like, I knew like Bob Odenkirk was in it and that was amazing and he was great, but I was very, I loved the structure of this one.
就像，我知道鲍勃·奥登科克在其中，这太棒了，他很棒，但我非常，我喜欢这个结构。
You know what I think is maybe, I think that sometimes the ones that are about deeply about friendship and deeply about love are the ones that get into the Mount Rushmore of how I made a mother.
你知道我的想法是什么，我认为有时那些深深地关于友谊和深深地关于爱的东西是那些进入拉什莫尔山的东西，这些东西是我如何成为一个母亲的。
And this one is really about money and career and respect.
这实际上是关于金钱、事业和尊重的。
Like it's a different, which by the way, in your late 20s and early 30s is deeply important.
顺便说一句，这对于 20 岁末和 30 岁出头的人来说非常重要。
It's not like it's unimportant to us right now, you know?
现在这对我们来说并不是不重要，你知道吗？
But I think there's something about Marshall already feeling like he's kind of tied himself in knots or twisted himself in shapes to make this job work.
但我认为马歇尔已经感觉自己为了完成这项工作而陷入困境或扭曲自己。
And then he realizes like his dignity is getting throttled, you know?
然后他意识到他的尊严正在受到扼杀，你知道吗？
Yes, yes.
是的，是的。
Is this how I want to live my life?
这就是我想要的生活吗？
Am I living adult life correctly?
我的成人生活正确吗？
It's one of those where you don't quite know who you are yet.
这是你还不知道自己是谁的人之一。
The cement has not dried on you or your career or where you're standing in life at all.
你、你的事业或你生活中的地位根本没有干涸。
and you're like, wait, where the fuck am I?
然后你会想，等等，我他妈的在哪儿？
And I'm impressed with this in this rewatch so far.
到目前为止，我在这次重看中对此印象深刻。
Here we are, middle of season three, further than middle.
我们现在已经是第三季的中间了，比中间更远了。
And there's a lot of good stuff about career, just what you just said.
正如你刚才所说，关于职业生涯有很多好东西。
There's a lot, it's this romantic comedy, that's the category it was put in, that's the shelf it would be on in the bookstore.
有很多，这是一部浪漫喜剧，这就是它被放入的类别，这就是它在书店的书架上。
But like, we do a lot about finding yourself in other ways in your late 20s, early 30s.
但是，就像我们在 20 岁末、30 岁出头时做了很多事情，以其他方式寻找自己。
And I'd forgotten how many of those are good, how many episodes of that or hold their weight?
我忘记了其中有多少是好的，有多少集是有分量的？
This might be waiting into kind of territory that we would dance around delicately, but I think part of wanting a good career is you want to be attractive to a mate.
这可能正在等待我们微妙地跳舞的领域，但我认为想要一份好的职业的一部分是你想要对伴侣有吸引力。
Yeah.
是的。
And you want to be able to provide for your wife and your future, your imaginary wife and your imaginary children, yeah, there's a lot that goes and they're not, what I'm saying is they're inextricably linked.
你希望能够养活你的妻子和你的未来，你想象中的妻子和你想象中的孩子，是的，有很多事情发生，但他们没有，我的意思是他们是密不可分的。
Yeah.
是的。
search for romance, the search for love and connection and partnership in your 20s and 30s, and your ambition and your wanting to make a name for yourself and achieve in the industry you've chosen.
寻找浪漫，寻找20多岁和30多岁的爱情、联系和伙伴关系，以及你的野心和想要在你选择的行业中成名并取得成就的愿望。
Those are really woven together in ways that I don't think people talk about enough.
这些确实以我认为人们谈论得不够多的方式交织在一起。
Yeah, I mean, it's part of this.
是的，我的意思是，这是其中的一部分。
We always talk about how there's this kind of second adolescence at the end of your 20s into your 30s, and it's maybe the more important one, and you're not really an adult yet then.
我们总是谈论在20多岁到30多岁时会有第二个青春期，这可能是更重要的一个，而那时你还不是真正的成年人。
And I think this is one of those moments of like, what kind of grown up am I becoming?
我认为这是这样的时刻之一，我正在成为什么样的成年人？
Am I becoming the kind of grown up who can get screamed at on a Tuesday morning?
我是否正在成为那种在周二早上会被尖叫的成年人？
And I'm just supposed to act like that's okay.
我应该表现得好像那没什么问题。
And it's such a glimpse into Barney's world and who he is, it is like, I got screamed at three times today, it's just like, do I want to live a life where that's normal?
这是对巴尼世界和他是谁的一瞥，就像，我今天被尖叫了三遍，就像，我想过一种正常的生活吗？
The shot where they introduced Blowman and Billson, is Brian's character Billson?
他们介绍布洛曼和比尔森的镜头，是布莱恩扮演的角色比尔森吗？
Is that Billson?
那是比尔森吗？
Okay, so Billson and Blowman, which I would say are in the Mount Rushmore of a hymnium side character.
好吧，比尔森和布洛曼，我想说的是，他们是赞美诗中拉什莫尔山的配角。
Side character is absolutely.
侧面性格绝对是。
Ghost of the Lamen is an unbelievable combo.
拉门之魂是一个令人难以置信的组合。
But the shot, the pan across the conference room of Barney's, the guys he works with.
但是镜头，镜头穿过巴尼的会议室，以及与他一起工作的人。
And just the ease that with which he's just slouched in that chair looking at his phone.
还有他无精打采地坐在椅子上看手机的轻松自在。
He's not even noticing the screaming.
他甚至没有注意到尖叫声。
He's like, he's texting.
他就像，他在发短信。
And he only pricks up when a guy starts to try to urinate on the conference table.
只有当有人开始尝试在会议桌上小便时，他才会勃起。
That's the only thing that suddenly that rates a little bit of attention.
这是唯一突然引起一点关注的事情。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我给你写了这首小曲，是为了在纽约唱给你听。
We'll be right back, back to the show.
我们马上回来，回到演出现场。
That little scene, every now and again in life, as writers or artists, whatever, you get to steal something.
那个小场景，在生活中时不时地出现，作为作家或艺术家，无论什么，你都会偷一些东西。
You never knew what to do.
你永远不知道该做什么。
You know, you have some idea and you're like, I don't know what that is.
你知道，你有一些想法，但我不知道那是什么。
I don't know what I'll ever do with that.
我不知道我会用它做什么。
I just, when I was in a job, I was ready to be out of one time.
我只是，当我在工作的时候，我就准备好离开一次。
I imagined a short film, and this was the short film.
我想象了一部短片，这就是短片。
The short film was, a guy comes in, and this is his plan.
短片是，一个人进来了，这就是他的计划。
He's gonna get him on the conference room table, give him a big speech, unzip, and just fucking fire hose all over that conference room table, and then he can't, he has stage, right?
他会让他坐在会议室的桌子上，给他一个重要的演讲，拉开拉链，然后在会议室的桌子上放满他妈的消防水龙带，然后他就不能了，他有舞台，对吧？
And it was just like a random short film idea, like I jotted it down in a notebook.
这就像一个随机的短片想法，就像我把它记在笔记本上一样。
I'm like, I'm not going to make this short film.
我想，我不会制作这部短片。
The world doesn't need a short film, but what better plot to us for Blowman?
世界不需要短片，但对于布洛曼来说，还有什么更好的情节呢？
Every now and again, you find a way, when you, this is one of the joys of a long-running TV show, you're like, we could do that, we could just do that little vignette.
时不时地，你会找到一种方法，当你，这是长期播出的电视节目的乐趣之一时，你会想，我们可以做到这一点，我们可以做那个小插曲。
And Taryn is so funny in that scene, it's a really funny scene.
塔林在那个场景中非常有趣，这是一个非常有趣的场景。
Well, it's almost like the best, the best thievery is from yourself as a writer, you know?
好吧，这几乎就像是最好的，最好的盗窃来自于你自己作为一个作家，你知道吗？
It feels the best.
感觉是最好的。
You know, what else is really interesting about this watching it 20 years on, I feel like when we did this episode, you know, 2008, there was still this idea, especially like, you know, doing a mail room at an agency or working with, say, Scott Rudin, where you knew that you were going to be kind of abused in a, there were those famous yellers, Scott Rudin was well-known.
你知道，20 年后看这个节目还有什么真正有趣的地方，我觉得当我们制作这一集时，你知道，2008 年，仍然有这个想法，特别是，你知道，在一家机构做收发室，或者与斯科特·鲁丁（Scott Rudin）合作，在那里你知道你会受到某种虐待，那里有那些著名的大喊大叫者，斯科特·鲁丁（Scott Rudin）是众所周知的。
Then a kind of like byproduct of me too was it was like, it wasn't just about sexual, It was like emotional abuse.
然后我也有一种副产品，那就是，这不仅仅是性方面的问题，这就像情感虐待。
And people don't abuse people.
人们不会虐待别人。
Don't abuse people.
不要虐待人。
Like that is not acceptable.
这样是不可接受的。
And I don't think that like the younger generations, like they won't stand for that.
我不认为像年轻一代那样他们不会忍受这一点。
Like they will not be yelled at in that way, which I think is a good thing.
就像他们不会那样被吼叫，我认为这是一件好事。
Like I've never believed in like, you know, drill sergeant kind of bosses.
就像我从来不相信像教官那样的老板。
I just think it's a, but there's something about it used to be this bit, like a bit of a rite of passage.
我只是认为这是一个，但它曾经有一些东西，就像一个成人仪式。
Like if you could withstand, for instance, My friend of mine was Scott Rudin's assistant for about eight or nine months, which was long.
比如说，如果你能承受的话，我的一个朋友担任斯科特·鲁丁（Scott Rudin）的助理大约八九个月，这是很长的。
That was a long tenure.
那是一个很长的任期。
That's really long.
那真的很长。
That is a veteran to last eight months.
那是一位能坚持八个月的老兵。
And afterwards, if you had that on your resume, you could kind of call your shot for your next job.
之后，如果你的简历上有这些，你就可以决定你的下一份工作了。
Like, wow.
就像，哇。
Yeah, like everyone knew, like if you had weathered that, you were made of some strong stuff.
是的，就像每个人都知道的那样，如果你经受住了这些考验，你就会由一些坚固的东西组成。
You were a marathon runner, you had climbed Everest.
你是一名马拉松运动员，你曾攀登过珠穆朗玛峰。
Yeah.
是的。
It's, I mean, of course, there are still places this is the culture, plenty of them, and probably more, and now it is, I would say, in our current climate of America.
我的意思是，当然，仍然有一些地方有这种文化，很多，甚至可能更多，而且现在，我想说，在美国目前的气候下。
But it is certainly a question you want to ask yourself, do you want to, am I signing up for a life where this is okay?
但这肯定是你想问自己的一个问题，你想吗，我是否愿意过一种可以接受的生活？
And this like, karmic idea of like, you should totally yell at the person, you have power over.
就像这样的业力想法，你应该完全对那个人大喊大叫，你有权力。
And Barney's whole solution is, go yell at this guy bringing you food at the diner.
巴尼的整个解决方案是，去对这个在餐馆给你送食物的人大喊大叫。
It just is like, well, you've got to get it Now it's somewhere, it really is, it's karma, right?
就像，好吧，你必须得到它现在它在某个地方，它确实是，这是业力，对吧？
We're studying the idea of karma.
我们正在研究业力的概念。
And it's, do you perpetuate the cycle of abuse?
问题是，你是否会延续虐待的循环？
I think a lot of people have this in there, like their parents were a certain way, they grew up a certain way, how did they then treat their kids?
我想很多人都有这样的想法，就像他们的父母以某种方式长大，他们以某种方式长大，然后他们如何对待他们的孩子？
It's just this idea of, do you end it?
只是这个想法，你结束它吗？
Or do you perpetuate it?
或者你会延续它吗？
And Barney is pro-perpetuating the yowl, he's like, yeah, just yell at someone that's powerful than you, that should clear it up.
巴尼支持继续咆哮，他就像，是的，只要对比你强大的人大喊大叫，就可以解决问题。
Well, it's also, it goes in a little bit of the book of like look at what Barney doesn't do the opposite to live a good, you know, virtuous life.
嗯，书里也有这样的内容，比如看看巴尼没有做相反的事情来过上美好的、你知道的、有道德的生活。
Yeah.
是的。
And you know, there's also so much in comedy around punching up, punching down.
你知道，喜剧里也有很多关于上拳、下拳的内容。
And you know, the truism is like punch up, punch, punch the powerful, don't punch the less powerful, like don't punch people that have less power and privilege than you do.
你知道，这个不言而喻的道理就像打拳、打拳、打有权势的人，不要打权力较弱的人，就像不要打那些权力和特权比你小的人。
So.
所以。
Amen.
阿门。
Yeah.
是的。
But you know, it was, it's great to watch Barney be like we say confidently wrong.
但你知道，看到巴尼像我们自信地说错了一样，真是太棒了。
He's just so confidently wrong in the midst of like Marshall is still trying to crack the code and speak the language of corporate culture because he's not to the man or born.
他只是如此自信地错了，就像马歇尔仍在试图破解密码并说出企业文化的语言一样，因为他不是一个男人或天生的。
Like this is not his native tongue.
好像这不是他的母语。
But yeah, I found myself really liking the stakes of Marshall saying it's a very little line in the episode.
但是，是的，我发现自己真的很喜欢马歇尔的赌注，他说这是剧集中的一句很小的台词。
He just says, Lily supported me through law school and now it's my turn to pay her back and just that is a very adult pressure, right?
他只是说，莉莉支持我读完法学院，现在轮到我回报她了，这就是一个非常成人的压力，对吧？
That's Marshall going, I need to do this for her.
这是马歇尔的主意，我需要为她做这件事。
I need to suffer through this to pay for our life.
我需要承受这些痛苦来偿还我们的生命。
And that's a very real thing, right?
这是非常真实的事情，对吧？
And it just, I'm gonna give up, I'm gonna now be miserable for a bunch of years because I need to pay this mortgage and Lily supported me.
只是，我要放弃了，我现在会痛苦很多年，因为我需要偿还抵押贷款，而莉莉支持我。
And I love that little scene between them at the end where Lily goes like, no, don't do that.
我喜欢最后他们之间的那个小场景，莉莉说，不，不要那样做。
We're gonna figure this out somehow.
我们会以某种方式解决这个问题。
I can't have you be miserable like this.
我不能让你这么痛苦。
And it's just, it's very sweet and supportive, that little scene between the two of them.
只是，他们两个之间的那个小场景非常甜蜜和支持。
And it doesn't solve the problem, Marshall, they, but she says we can, we're gonna figure this out.
这并不能解决问题，马歇尔，他们，但她说我们可以，我们会解决这个问题。
And I was, I felt a lot of relief watching that for Marshall, because I think as someone's as men and certainly men of a certain age growing up, you have this feeling like I, but I must provide.
我看到马歇尔的表现让我松了一口气，因为我认为作为男人，当然是在一定年龄成长的男人，你和我一样有这种感觉，但我必须提供。
This is what men do.
这就是男人所做的。
We shall start to provide.
我们将开始提供。
And I just liked Lilly saying, no, I like happy, I like happy Marshall.
我只是喜欢莉莉说，不，我喜欢快乐，我喜欢快乐的马歇尔。
I want that guy.
我想要那个家伙。
That was sweet, they're a good couple.
真是太甜蜜了，他们是一对很好的情侣。
It's not worth the trade-off, you know, like what you're getting and then who you become as a result.
你知道，这种权衡是不值得的，就像你所得到的以及你因此而成为的人。
And then you have no energy left for your relationship.
然后你就没有精力去维持你们的关系了。
Like the person you fell in love with is not- And she's not getting any.
就像你爱上的人不是——而她却没有得到任何。
She's not getting any.
她什么也得不到。
She's totally, she's what she needs to have emotional and wants to- Yeah.
她完全是，她就是她需要有情感并且想要-是的。
That's the party.
这就是聚会。
Yeah.
是的。
I really thought it was so funny and clever and such a good use of the gang.
我真的觉得这很有趣，很聪明，对这帮人的利用很好。
Well, first of all, Bob's thing of Arthur, that's his name in the episode, right?
好吧，首先，鲍勃的亚瑟之物，那是他在这一集中的名字，对吗？
Arthur's thing of like coming in and being incredibly kind to the person in the office next door.
亚瑟喜欢走进来并对隔壁办公室的人非常友善。
So funny.
太有趣了。
Psychopathically, just switching on a dime to script.
精神变态地，只需立即切换到脚本即可。
But that reveal of that father-daughter day, for some reason.
但出于某种原因，那个父女节的揭露。
Can you believe he did this and take your daughter to work?
你能相信他这样做并带你女儿去上班吗？
Take your daughter to work day and then the daughter to speak the offer by the way.
白天带你女儿去上班，然后女儿顺便说一下offer。
out from under.
从下面出来。
Oh my god.
我的天啊。
That was, I forgot about that joke and it really tickled me and really surprised me.
也就是说，我忘记了那个笑话，它真的让我很高兴，也让我很惊讶。
Such a simple, like classic, simple comedic reveal.
如此简单、经典、简单的喜剧揭示。
Like just so, so wonderful.
就像这样，太美妙了。
But I really loved when the gang gathers together in the bar and everyone says, here's what you should do.
但我真的很喜欢当这帮人聚集在酒吧里，每个人都说，这就是你应该做的。
And then everyone walks in as martial.
然后每个人都以武士的身份走进去。
Like where'd that come from?
就像那是从哪里来的？
That's such a smart idea and it's such a good way for the gang to be, to transport themselves into the office into Marshall's story.
这是一个非常聪明的主意，对于这帮人来说，这是一个很好的方式，让他们把自己带进办公室，融入到马歇尔的故事中。
It was just, yeah, it was a structure.
是的，它只是一个结构。
It was a way to keep everyone on the A story, which we keep talking about on the show, how those are usually the best ones, where it's not fractured into ABC, D-Stories, and everyone's kind of separate, and maybe it comes together at the end.
这是一种让每个人都关注 A 故事的方法，我们在节目中一直在谈论这些故事通常是最好的故事，它不会分裂成 ABC 故事、D 故事，每个人都是分开的，也许最后会走到一起。
Some of those can be great, we've done good ones of those, but everybody didn't have a thing in this episode.
其中一些可能很棒，我们已经做得很好了，但每个人在这一集中都没有什么。
People's things were, here's what I'd do, and then they get their sketch comedy scene.
人们的事情是，这就是我要做的，然后他们就得到了喜剧小品场景。
Right.
正确的。
Well, Ted had a new car.
嗯，特德有一辆新车。
Ted had a new car.
特德有一辆新车。
Ted has his new car.
特德有了他的新车。
That was a good extra bit and that being very nervous about all this is increasingly perilous food coming in with cats and with that enormous I can't go that's delicious enough that's delicious enough what a life she's she's so funny with that yeah but I like it was it's funny because Bob Odenkirk is the creator of one of the greatest sketch comedy shows of all time Mr. Show.
这是一个很好的额外一点，对这一切感到非常紧张，因为猫带来的食物越来越危险，而且这么大，我不能去，那足够美味，足够美味，她的生活真是太有趣了，是的，但我喜欢它很有趣，因为鲍勃·奥登科克是有史以来最伟大的喜剧小品节目之一的创作者。
And I don't know if that informed the structure of like, because this is kind of a sketch show for a minute, right?
我不知道这是否说明了类似的结构，因为这有点像素描表演，对吧？
It's just everybody's going to do that same sketch.
只是每个人都会画同样的草图。
And I think I just think that was a great structure.
我想我只是认为这是一个很棒的结构。
And everybody together.
和大家在一起。
And the gang all weighing in on one idea is always good.
所有人都在同一个想法上进行权衡总是好的。
You look at them and you're like, I understand why people watch this show and go, I want to hang out with those people.
你看着他们，你就会想，我明白为什么人们看这个节目然后走，我想和那些人一起出去玩。
I want my version of those people.
我想要那些人的我的版本。
The people who go, So ooh, and they hear the word ninja.
去的人，哦，他们听到了忍者这个词。
There's just enough uniformity and shared language and inside joke that it makes you feel seen and heard and loved, and just enough stress and strain and conflict to make you feel like you're all growing each other up together.
有足够的一致性、共同的语言和内部笑话，让你感到被看到、被听到和被爱，也有足够的压力、紧张和冲突，让你觉得你们在一起成长。
Yeah, I like the simple moment where Marshall at the very beginning, it's the funny thing about Ted's car, and then Marshall walks by looking catatonic.
是的，我喜欢马歇尔一开始的简单时刻，泰德的车很有趣，然后马歇尔走过，看起来很紧张。
And just the immediacy with which everyone's like, what's wrong?
每个人都喜欢的即时性，有什么问题吗？
And then they just all huddle around and they're all going to solve that problem.
然后他们就挤在一起解决这个问题。
I had this weird kind of envy of that.
我对此有一种奇怪的嫉妒。
I was like, I want all my friends to huddle up and solve my problems.
我当时想，我希望所有的朋友都聚在一起解决我的问题。
That doesn't happen enough.
这还不够。
Thank you for doing that TV episode 17 years ago.
谢谢你 17 年前制作的那部电视剧。
And now to mention this podcast today, why did you agree to do this 17 years ago?
现在今天要提这个播客，为什么17年前你会同意这样做呢？
What about?
又怎样呢？
You didn't know us anything back then.
那时你对我们一无所知。
No, and I don't think I knew anybody.
不，我想我不认识任何人。
I mean, I did because I was writing.
我的意思是，我这么做是因为我在写作。
Yeah.
是的。
I was writing TV shows that were not going anywhere.
我正在写的电视节目没有任何进展。
Yeah.
是的。
Like I was, you know, I had, they would always get like pilot deals or script deal.
就像我一样，你知道，我曾经有过，他们总是会得到试播协议或剧本协议。
And so, you know, it's a development hall And getting to make something, you know, getting on a set, you know, and making something, it's up.
所以，你知道，这是一个开发大厅，开始制作一些东西，你知道，进入片场，你知道，制作一些东西，就这样了。
Yeah, you get distance from that over time and you just want to connect with it.
是的，随着时间的推移，你会与它保持距离，你只想与之建立联系。
So, you know, the show is very respected show.
所以，你知道，这个节目是非常受人尊敬的节目。
So, you know, I mean, absolutely, that's a yes to do that, to be a part of that.
所以，你知道，我的意思是，绝对是这样做，成为其中的一部分。
I think it was better for me.
我认为这对我来说更好。
know that this caused the, uh, the situation with Mike Ermitrop to be created at Breaking Bad.
我知道这导致了，呃，《绝命毒师》中迈克·厄米特罗普的情况。
And I'm not sure if it was this episode or a later episode.
我不确定这是这一集还是后面的一集。
Alec, can you do a little numbers crunching, Alec?
亚历克，你能做一些数字运算吗，亚历克？
I, I produced for Alec and see you in real time if this was the one that's, that definitely did happen.
我，我为亚历克制作，如果这确实发生过，我会实时见到你。
There's this crazy to figure it out.
弄清楚这个问题真是太疯狂了。
You need to figure out when season two of Breaking Bad was shot, not shown shot.
你需要弄清楚《绝命毒师》第二季的拍摄时间，而不是拍摄时间。
Right.
正确的。
Yeah, but we had you, we, I'll just say for the, to describe it to people that don't know we're talking about, we booked you for something and then Breaking Bad turned out to need you to perform a certain like plot function in an episode of Breaking Bad, but we had you, which I guess they fucking hated us probably, like, oh no, it's a little bit, um, it's, it's a soft, uh, scenario in that Breaking Bad said we need him for three or four episodes.
是的，但是我们有你，我们，我只想说，为了向那些不知道我们在谈论的人描述它，我们为你预订了一些东西，然后《绝命毒师》需要你在《绝命毒师》的一集中执行某种类似的情节功能，但我们有你，我想他们可能他妈的讨厌我们，就像，哦不，有点，嗯，这是一个软，呃，场景，《绝命毒师》说我们需要他三到四集。
not sure which.
不确定是哪一个。
Right.
正确的。
And when we did the math on the calendar, you guys had said, we need you for this episode, which is like a month from now.
当我们计算日历时，你们说，我们需要你们来参加这一集，大约是一个月后的事。
But even with you guys, it was a little uncertain.
但即使和你们在一起，还是有点不确定。
It was less uncertain than breaking bad, but it was still like, we think we've got this story for him, honestly, maybe six weeks from now.
这比坏事更不确定，但我们仍然认为，老实说，我们认为我们已经为他准备了这个故事，也许六周后。
It was a ways off, but we had said yes to that, and I either knew you and had done the show, or I think I knew you guys.
虽然还有很长的路要走，但我们已经同意了，我要么认识你们并且完成了这个节目，要么我想我认识你们。
So it was like, I already said yes to them, and I know them.
所以就好像，我已经答应了他们，而且我了解他们。
So I'm guessing it was a later episode.
所以我猜这是后来的一集。
Anyhow, you did need me, and because we always need you.
不管怎样，你确实需要我，因为我们总是需要你。
Yeah, because Saul wasn't there available, then they had to create Mike, but then they were thankful for that, because the situation that they were trying to sort out was the Jesse's girlfriend was dead, and they needed to move the body, and he had called Saul to help them, and they realized like, well, Saul wouldn't move a body, so you'd have to, he'd create something, he'd create something.
是的，因为扫罗不在场，所以他们必须创造迈克，但他们对此很感激，因为他们试图解决的情况是杰西的女朋友死了，他们需要移动尸体，他打电话给扫罗来帮助他们，他们意识到，好吧，扫罗不会移动尸体，所以你必须这样做，他会创造一些东西，他会创造一些东西。
So it was actually better than it was this other person, because it would have been a little out of character for Saul, is that the take away?
所以它实际上比另一个人更好，因为这对扫罗来说有点不符合性格，这是要点吗？
Totally out of character for Saul, And honestly, so much of Breaking Bad, like so many shows and movies, there's that thing of like, we wanted this, but we couldn't get it.
完全不符合索尔的性格，老实说，《绝命毒师》的很多内容，就像很多电视剧和电影一样，有这样的事情，我们想要这个，但我们无法得到它。
So we created the thing that saves the show.
所以我们创造了拯救这部剧的东西。
You know, in the case of Breaking Bad, I mean, they were gonna kill Jesse in that first season.
你知道，就《绝命毒师》而言，我的意思是，他们会在第一季杀死杰西。
And then the writer's guilt strike happened.
然后作家的内疚罢工发生了。
Well, that's this, that's this.
嗯，就是这个，就是这个。
That is when this episode we shot with you is coming.
那就是我们和你一起拍摄的这一集的时间。
This is like the second week out of the writer's guilt strike, basically is when, is this chain of screaming episode?
这就像编剧的内疚罢工的第二周，基本上是什么时候，这是一连串的尖叫插曲吗？
So maybe said the mic thing must have been actually later, right?
所以也许说麦克风的事情实际上一定是后来的，对吧？
So this is when, yeah, isn't it?
所以这就是时候，是的，不是吗？
People don't realize how much practicality guides, huge impactful, creative decisions in our business.
人们没有意识到我们的业务中有多少实用性指导、巨大影响力和创造性决策。
I'm sure like doing Mr. Show, you were constantly like, well, how do we do this on this budget?
我确信就像拍摄《秀先生》一样，你总是会想，好吧，我们如何在这个预算下做到这一点？
And you have ideas that just come about because of necessity as the mother of invention.
作为发明之母，你的想法只是因为需要而产生的。
I think people think we've had these brilliant ideas and we've planned things out.
我认为人们认为我们已经有了这些绝妙的想法并且我们已经计划好了。
Now, Breaking Bad couldn't have you, so now Mike exists, and it's because of us.
现在，《绝命毒师》不能拥有你，所以现在迈克存在了，这是因为我们。
It's the weirdest, that is so weird.
这是最奇怪的，太奇怪了。
But great, there's something great about that.
但太棒了，这有一些很棒的东西。
Really great.
真的很棒。
And honestly, I did a movie, I'll brag a little.
老实说，我拍了一部电影，我会吹牛一点。
I did a Steven Spielberg movie called The Post, and he came to set and he'd be looking around and he was very happy to talk to us all about his process and things and on bragging, nearly bragging about how he didn't do storyboards ever.
我拍了一部史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格的电影，名叫《华盛顿邮报》，他来到片场，环顾四周，他很高兴和我们谈论他的制作过程、事情和吹牛，几乎吹嘘他从来没有做过故事板。
And how, in fact, not only did he not do storyboards, oftentimes he's never been on the set before.
事实上，他不仅不做故事板，而且很多时候他以前从未去过片场。
Or, you know, which is like, because there tend to be built sets.
或者，你知道，这就像，因为往往有内置的场景。
It's like amazing, he's literally saying no.
真是太神奇了，他真的在拒绝。
They're saying, come down and we'll show you the set, no.
他们说，下来，我们给你看布景，不。
I wanna get there on the day and be like, Oh shit, the door isn't where I thought it was in my mind.
我想有一天到达那里，然后说，哦，该死，门不在我想象的地方。
And I want there to be, cause he said the fun of this job is problem solving.
我希望有这样的经历，因为他说这份工作的乐趣在于解决问题。
The fun is getting there, it's not exactly what you pictured, but you know what you want emotionally, and now I have to figure it out.
有趣的是到达那里，它并不完全是你想象的那样，但你知道你在情感上想要什么，现在我必须弄清楚它。
And all these problems like, so, you know, it's gonna move the body and then Bob Odenkirk's not available.
所有这些问题就像，所以，你知道，它会移动身体，然后鲍勃·奥登科克就无法上场。
So, oh, well, well, that actually makes more sense because someone wouldn't move a body.
所以，哦，好吧，好吧，这实际上更有意义，因为有人不会移动尸体。
And who is Saul, and I was thinking about who he is, and who would he know, and...
扫罗是谁，我在想他是谁，他会认识谁，然后……
Maybe that would have changed Saul and sent him in a wrong direction and the character would have been different all of a sudden.
也许这会改变扫罗，把他引向错误的方向，性格会突然不同。
Maybe it was good for Saul, too.
也许这对索尔也有好处。
You know that Spielberg thing reminds me of certain actors who love when a prop drops or something doesn't work.
你知道斯皮尔伯格的事情让我想起某些喜欢道具掉落或出现故障的演员。
like something going wrong or off the rails is when they feel the most alive and the most in the moment.
就像出了问题或出轨的时候，他们感觉自己最有活力，最有活力。
I've worked with actors like that.
我和这样的演员合作过。
And, you know, I can trip myself into that, but I'm quite like that.
而且，你知道，我可能会陷入这样的境地，但我就是这样。
But I do have a very strong memory that you were, you were much more, I remember most of our talks because I started directing these indie films, like at some point I wasn't, I was working on them when you were here first.
但我确实有一个非常强烈的记忆，你是，你更多，我记得我们的大部分谈话，因为我开始导演这些独立电影，就像在某个时候我不是，当你第一次来这里时我正在制作它们。
We talked a lot about filmmaking and about writing.
我们谈论了很多关于电影制作和写作的事情。
And I remember you being really lit up by that.
我记得你对此感到非常高兴。
But there is something about when you're in the writing process, in the development hell, when you get a chance to guest start, it's like, oh, this is actually going to be shot and done and aired.
但是，当你在写作过程中，在开发地狱中，当你有机会客座开始时，就会感觉，哦，这实际上将被拍摄、完成并播出。
There's something satisfying about that when you're in that endless wheel of inaction that is.
当你处于无尽的无所作为的轮回中时，会有一些令人满意的东西。
It's the best.
这是最好的。
Yeah.
是的。
I mean, honestly, my agent called me about breaking that and he said, I'm going to tell it.
我的意思是，老实说，我的经纪人打电话给我，说我打破了这一点，他说，我要告诉它。
They want you for a part on a show.
他们想要你参加一个节目。
Don't say no to this one.
不要对这个说不。
And I was like, do I say no that much?
我就想，我有说那么多不吗？
Because like you say, Josh, when you're in that, that's your chapter of your career, however you get there that you're developing, you know, it's just a lot of sluggish, you know, one step forward, two steps back and time, time, time, take you forever.
因为就像你说的，乔什，当你处于其中时，那就是你职业生涯的篇章，无论你如何到达那里，你都在发展，你知道，这只是很多缓慢，你知道，前进一步，后退两步，时间，时间，时间，永远带走你。
And you know, I was, in my mind, I was like, I kind of say yes, because I just want to get on a set and make something, you know, and break this up, break this, uh, this chapter up with some actual shooting.
你知道，我在心里想，我有点同意，因为我只是想进入片场并制作一些东西，你知道，然后用一些实际的拍摄来打破这个，呃，这一章。
Um, and you guys were, uh, awesome for that.
嗯，你们真是，呃，太棒了。
You gave me that.
你给了我那个。
Jeff me going and I met not only that, Josh.
杰夫我走了，我不仅遇到了乔希。
I want to tell you, when I got there, that crew of people, that cast Allison and Kobe and Neil and Jason and you, um, the spirit that you guys had was like, I actually thought it was like, are you being, are you mocking this?
我想告诉你，当我到达那里时，那群人，演员艾利森、科比、尼尔和杰森，还有你们，嗯，你们的精神就像，我真的以为这就像，你们在嘲笑这个吗？
Are you sarcastic?
你讽刺吗？
Because you guys are so gung ho, you were so upbeat and gung ho.
因为你们是如此的热情，你们是如此的乐观和热情。
And, uh, I was like, I really didn't believe it at first.
而且，呃，我当时想，一开始我真的不相信。
And then the more I came back, the more I realized, oh, that's, that's how you guys are looking at this.
然后我回来得越多，我就越意识到，哦，那就是，你们就是这么看待这件事的。
You didn't see an attrition of the high spirits as the series went off.
随着系列赛的结束，你并没有看到高昂的情绪消失。
We stayed for you guys.
我们为你们留下来。
I didn't and I came later in the show.
我没有，我后来才参加演出。
I didn't start till the third season.
直到第三季我才开始。
So you guys carried that through an awful lot.
所以你们经历了很多事情。
If you dropped off with that later, I didn't see it.
如果你稍后带着它离开，我就没有看到。
But I was very, I literally thought you were being sarcastic.
但我真的觉得你是在讽刺。
I can't move.
我不能动。
That's amazing.
太棒了。
Like that's so funny, but I loved it.
就像这很有趣，但我喜欢它。
I loved it and you know, I learned from you guys, of course, that's how you should look at it.
我喜欢它，你知道，我向你们学习，当然，这就是你应该如何看待它。
It's very easy, especially on a first job, and it wasn't everyone's first job, and that might have helped, but it's very easy, especially on a first job to get jaded and just not appreciate what you are going on.
这很容易，尤其是在第一份工作上，而且这不是每个人的第一份工作，这可能会有所帮助，但这很容易，尤其是在第一份工作上，你会感到厌倦，只是不欣赏自己所做的事情。
I knew from guest starring, I always find guest starring to be the most emotionally precarious, I actually found it to be really hard to step into someone else's house as a guest and try to figure out the kind of lay of the land.
我从客串中知道，我一直觉得客串是感情上最不稳定的，其实我觉得以客串的身份走进别人的家，去揣摩别人的底细，真的很难。
So then once it was like my house, once I was in the series regulars and maybe it's like the Midwestern Ohio in me, I always wanted to make it extra comfortable for guest stars.
因此，一旦它就像我的房子，一旦我成为该系列的常客，也许它就像我心中的俄亥俄州中西部，我总是想让它为客串明星提供额外的舒适。
And I was also a fan of yours, I was a huge Mr. Show fan.
我也是你的粉丝，我是 Mr. Show 的超级粉丝。
Me too.
我也是。
So I was like, I was psyched to work with you.
所以我想，我很高兴能和你一起工作。
We were starting to have you there.
我们开始让你在那里。
We were our best behavior, to be fair, because everyone there was starstruck by you.
公平地说，我们表现得最好，因为那里的每个人都被你迷住了。
That's amazing.
太棒了。
I was in that headspace of writing, so I was distracted, you know, how it is.
我正处于写作的顶峰，所以我心烦意乱，你知道，事情是这样的。
You know, you never not, you're, I tried to explain it to my wife once, you know, I always said to her, I said to her, when you look at me and I'm doing something, washing the dishes, making dinner, whatever, just always remember I'm doing two things.
你知道，你永远不会，你，我曾经试图向我的妻子解释，你知道，我总是对她说，我对她说，当你看着我时，我正在做某事，洗碗，做晚饭，无论什么，只要永远记住我在做两件事。
Yes.
是的。
I'm doing the thing that you see I'm doing, and I'm also trying to figure out that story that I'm writing.
我正在做你看到的我正在做的事情，而且我也在试图弄清楚我正在写的那个故事。
Yeah, I think non-writers, like civilians, like just normal grounded people really can't understand that we're all haunted all the time.
是的，我认为非作家，就像平民，就像普通的脚踏实地的人一样，真的无法理解我们一直都在闹鬼。
There's just never a moment you feel like you're not failing to come up with a thing.
从来没有一刻你会觉得自己没有想出任何办法。
I read something that a writer said, one of the hardest parts of my life is trying to convince my wife that me lying on the couch and staring at the ceiling is work.
我读过一位作家说的，我一生中最困难的部分之一就是试图说服我的妻子，我躺在沙发上盯着天花板是工作。
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha!
哈哈哈哈哈哈哈！
And this old man he must've met me, fell in love with you, New York City, and now commercials.
这位老人他一定见过我，爱上了你，纽约市，现在又爱上了广告。
I'm Vincent Cunningham.
我是文森特·坎宁安。
I'm Naomi Frey, I'm Alex Schwartz and we host critics at large from The New Yorker.
我是娜奥米·弗雷 (Naomi Frey)，我是亚历克斯·施瓦茨 (Alex Schwartz)，我们接待来自《纽约客》的广大评论家。
Each week we pick a starting point, the new novel you can't stop thinking about, movie everybody see in this weekend and we kind of go galaxy brand with it right we take the ideas at the center of these things and trace them across history across mediums all to get to the bottom of why this particular text is important right now in politics and culture and also in your everyday life we go highbrow we go lowbrow we go everything in between food culture to meme culture charlie xcx to Tony Morrison.
每周我们都会选择一个起点，你无法停止思考的新小说，这个周末每个人都会看的电影，我们有点像银河品牌，我们以这些事物为中心的想法，并通过各种媒介追踪它们的历史，以深入了解为什么这个特定的文本现在在政治和文化以及你的日常生活中很重要，我们走高雅，我们走低俗，我们从饮食文化到模因文化查理·xcx到托尼·莫里森之间的一切。
K-pop to the Kennedys, from horror movies to heated rivalry, from the Oscars to the Med Gala, the Golden Bachelor of Wuthering Heights, great expectations to Desperate Housewives.
韩国流行音乐到肯尼迪家族，从恐怖电影到激烈角逐，从奥斯卡颁奖典礼到 Med Gala，呼啸山庄的金学士，对绝望主妇的厚望。
That's what we're talking about over here.
这就是我们在这里讨论的内容。
We're having fun.
我们玩得很开心。
It's critics at large from the New Yorker.
这是来自《纽约客》的广泛批评。
Every Thursday, wherever you get your podcasts.
每个星期四，无论您在哪里获取播客。
End of commercials?
广告完结了？
Back to show.
返回展示。
You know, the crazy thing, the other sign that is so often those solutions come to you when You're not trying to think of them when you're right when you stop doing that and would you stop?
你知道，疯狂的事情，另一个迹象是，当你不试图思考它们时，当你停止这样做时，这些解决方案经常会出现在你身上，当你是对的时，你会停下来吗？
Yeah, can we I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna take the kid to the dentist and the whole time.
是的，我们可以吗？我要去，我要去，我要带孩子去看牙医，一直都这样。
I'm gonna work out why this character wants that I'm gonna work on that thoughtfully and you don't you don't come up with anything But then you go to sleep and you wake up and go like or you watch a movie and you really I think you go Of course she wants this, you know, you know, 100% and I find that as I get older that is I'm so much more interested in that like on the unconscious part of creativity like where it just it will come new I think is a younger person like no I've got to force this all the time.
我会弄清楚为什么这个角色想要我会深思熟虑地工作，你不会想出任何东西但是然后你去睡觉然后你醒来然后就像或者你看电影然后你真的我想你会去当然她想要这个，你知道，你知道，100%，我发现随着我年龄的增长，我对创造力的无意识部分更感兴趣，就像它会出现新的一样，我认为是一个年轻人，就像没有我必须一直强迫这样做。
And it's not really true.
这并不是真的。
You have to work hard but you had the idea part you can let happen sometimes and you know Bob you told me something it wasn't the first episode it was that you did it was later when I was already directing.
你必须努力工作，但你有想法，有时你可以让它发生，你知道鲍勃你告诉我一些事情，这不是第一集，而是你在后来我已经导演的时候做到的。
but we were talking about shooting movies and I was shooting with two cameras a lot.
但我们谈论的是拍摄电影，我经常用两台相机拍摄。
We had two cameras in a lot of days.
很多天我们都有两台相机。
And I remember you saying, you don't like it when they do a medium shot and a close up in the same thing because it doesn't give the actor the chance to modify their performance from the medium to the close.
我记得你说过，你不喜欢他们在同一件事上做中景和特写镜头，因为这没有给演员机会从中景到特写调整他们的表演。
And I always thought about that.
我一直在想这个。
I always thought that's actually quite smart.
我一直认为这实际上很聪明。
I don't like that at all.
我一点也不喜欢这样。
Yeah, yeah, that never, that's always stayed with me.
是的，是的，那从来没有，那一直伴随着我。
Well, it depends on what you're shooting, Josh.
好吧，这取决于你要拍摄什么，乔什。
I mean, the tone of the piece matters a lot because there's things that are really fun to watch in a quote unquote documentary style, you know, just a, I'm just documenting these human beings doing this thing and there can be more, you're not working with lenses and the tone as much.
我的意思是，这部作品的基调很重要，因为有些事情以纪录片的风格观看确实很有趣，你知道，只是，我只是记录这些人做这件事，还可以有更多，你不用太多地处理镜头和基调。
But you gotta know when it works and when it doesn't because as you point out, sometimes that traditional style is it's not great.
但你必须知道它什么时候有效，什么时候无效，因为正如你所指出的，有时传统风格并不好。
I mean like you you want to say to the filmmaker or the director like this is not where the value of this piece resides in that tone that you're carefully sculpting.
我的意思是，像你一样，你想对电影制片人或导演说，这并不是这部作品的价值所在，而是你精心塑造的基调。
It would be so much better to just watch these people talk to each other and believe they lived in the world and you don't try to choreograph an emotional tone through the whole thing.
如果只是看着这些人互相交谈并相信他们生活在这个世界上，而不是试图在整个过程中编排情感基调，那就好多了。
Yeah, yeah, so do you have memories of of this first episode like we watch it We both watched it last night and I watched it today.
是的，是的，那么你对我们观看的第一集有记忆吗？我们昨晚都看了，今天也看了。
I thought it was great.
我觉得这太棒了。
Yeah, I'll be out of it to you The show while it was shot in the unique way With no audience.
是的，我会向你展示这部剧以独特的方式拍摄的，没有观众。
Did you ever have an audience?
你曾经有过观众吗？
Sorry?
对不起？
That's David Cross calling me.
那是大卫·克罗斯给我打电话。
Oh David Cross calling guys get him on here It's a nice to show reunion on the How We Made Your Mother podcast, put them on.
噢，大卫·克罗斯（David Cross）打电话给大家，让他上来。在“我们如何创造你的母亲”播客上展示重聚真是太好了，把他们放上来吧。
He and I are showing a movie this weekend at the Tribeca Film Fest, we climb Machu Picchu and we documented it.
他和我这个周末将在翠贝卡电影节上放映一部电影，我们爬上马丘比丘并记录下来。
That's so cool.
太酷了。
I heard about that.
我听说过。
That's amazing.
太棒了。
Oh, my God.
我的天啊。
I live in Tribeca.
我住在翠贝卡。
I'll have to try to come to that.
我必须努力做到这一点。
It's just a hangout, Craig.
这只是一个聚会场所，克雷格。
It's just two old friends hanging out and doing this hard thing, and there's a little bit of learning but not a lot.
只是两个老朋友一起出去玩，做这件艰苦的事情，有一点学习，但不是很多。
And so you did the inka trail like the four day thing towards it.
所以你做了四天的印加足迹。
Okay, cool.
好吧，酷。
Amazing.
惊人的。
Yeah, that's amazing.
是的，那太棒了。
I have to see that.
我必须看到这一点。
Okay, that's a good plug.
好吧，这是一个很好的插头。
That's a good plug.
这是一个很好的插头。
What was it like for you to rewatch the episode?
你重温这一集的感觉如何？
Well, so the show, I honestly forgot the way in which the show was a unique half hour comedy in that it was more filmic than most of them by a lot and I would even include Larry Sanders in that because Larry Sanders didn't do the montage thing that you guys did.
好吧，所以这部剧，老实说，我忘记了这部剧是一部独特的半小时喜剧，因为它比大多数喜剧更具电影感，我什至会把拉里·桑德斯也包括在内，因为拉里·桑德斯没有像你们那样做蒙太奇事情。
You guys do a lot of montages or at least you did in that episode and that's and yet you know it was such an in-between show.
你们做了很多蒙太奇，或者至少在那一集里做了，但你们知道这是一个介于两者之间的节目。
It was so in between a normal half hour that you would shoot in front of an audience, a live audience, and a film, just pure film.
在正常的半小时内，你会在观众面前拍摄，现场观众，和一部电影，纯粹的电影。
So what I do remember, Josh, is my pieces were these short scenes, and that was a little weird, and they were seemingly somewhat disconnected.
所以我记得，乔什，我的作品是这些短场景，这有点奇怪，而且它们似乎有些脱节。
I like to think I read the whole script at one point, but it doesn't matter if I did or not, the character's behavior was unaffected by that awareness.
我喜欢认为我曾经读过整个剧本，但无论我是否读过，角色的行为都不会受到这种意识的影响。
It was kind of a sketch comedy episode, it was kind of, because it was these sketches of like...
这有点像喜剧小品，是这样，因为这些小品就像……
How many of us did you do, Craig?
克雷格，你做了我们当中的多少人？
Did you do that often?
你经常这样做吗？
Did we do it from the first season on, or did you, when did you first go?
我们是从第一季开始就这么做的，还是你，你第一次去的时候？
We're gonna break this form apart.
我们要把这个表格拆开。
We had no idea Carter Bayes and I, who are creators of the show, and super fans of yours, David Cross and Mr. Show, and you on Larry Sanders and everything in between, and since, we loved Mr. Show how strange and deconstructed it was, how it was just this strange meandering maze and setups and payoffs, and that's what we want to grow up and be like that.
我们不知道卡特·贝叶斯和我，他们是这部剧的创作者，也不知道你的超级粉丝，大卫·克罗斯和《秀先生》，以及你对拉里·桑德斯和介于两者之间的一切，因为我们喜欢《秀先生》，它是多么奇怪和解构，它是多么奇怪的蜿蜒迷宫、设置和回报，这就是我们想要成长并成为的样子。
We idolized you guys, and so we tried to do as much of that storytelling weirdness in a 22-minute at CBS sitcom, we always felt like we were Trojan Horse saying this really strange thing into like, you know, we were sandwiched between like King of Queens and two and a half men, but we were this really weird half hour, and we looked like we belonged, like it was shot, it looked like a sitcom, but it really, we would do very strange structures.
我们崇拜你们，所以我们试图在 CBS 情景喜剧的 22 分钟里讲出尽可能多的怪异故事，我们总觉得我们是特洛伊木马，说着这非常奇怪的事情，就像，你知道，我们被夹在皇后之王和两个半男人之间，但我们在这半个小时里真的很奇怪，我们看起来像我们所属的，就像它被拍摄一样，它看起来像一部情景喜剧，但实际上，我们会做非常奇怪的结构。
Like the main motor of this whole episode is everyone, all of Marshall's friends saying, here's what I would do, I'd march in, and here's how I'd handle this artillery arthur boss.
就像整个情节的主要动力是每个人，马歇尔的所有朋友都说，这就是我会做的，我会进军，这就是我会如何处理这个炮兵亚瑟老大。
And then you get to see a weird little skit that kind of comes from each one of their characters.
然后你会看到他们每个角色都有一个奇怪的小短剧。
And you get, and you have to be, you know, yes, ending that essentially in each of these like fantasies.
你得到了，而且你必须，你知道，是的，基本上以这些幻想结束。
And that's the best part of this whole episode.
这是整个情节中最好的部分。
And it's weird.
这很奇怪。
You know, it's like a weird storytelling spot.
你知道，这就像一个奇怪的讲故事的地方。
Do you not do that a lot, Craig?
克雷格，你不经常这样做吗？
We did.
我们做到了。
We would do episodes where it's everyone's sitting around kind of parsing out a problem and there's crazy flashbacks and there's flash forwards and there's fantasies.
我们会制作这样的剧集，每个人都坐在一起解析问题，有疯狂的闪回，有闪进，还有幻想。
We loved that.
我们喜欢那个。
We loved chopping that up.
我们喜欢把它切碎。
As we go through and doing this re-watch podcast, Josh and I haven't watched a lot of these episodes in years.
当我们重新观看这个播客时，乔什和我已经很多年没有看过很多这样的剧集了。
All the best episodes are ones where it's not A story, B story, C story.
所有最好的剧集都不是 A 故事、B 故事、C 故事。
Every once in a while, we were given notes or we felt like, we should be a little more traditional.
每隔一段时间，我们就会收到笔记，或者我们觉得我们应该更传统一点。
We're on CBS, we don't want to get canceled.
我们在哥伦比亚广播公司，我们不想被取消。
We've got to fit in and we would do more traditional episodes.
我们必须融入，我们会做更多传统的剧集。
And every one of those, as we watch them, we're like, these ones aren't as good.
当我们看到其中的每一个时，我们都会想，这些都没有那么好。
They're good enough, but they're not as good.
它们足够好，但还不够好。
And the ones that are weird and unique and everyone's just on the fucking A story.
还有那些奇怪而独特的，每个人都只是在讲他妈的故事。
There's just one thing and then you find little ways to kind of dovetail up and they go like weird little side trips and just chop up one big story, but everybody's kind of on the same track in some way.
只有一件事，然后你找到一些方法来吻合，它们就像奇怪的小支线旅行一样，只是把一个大故事切碎，但每个人在某种程度上都在同一条轨道上。
Those are all the best ones.
这些都是最好的。
And this one, we forgot how much we liked this episode.
而这一集，我们忘记了我们有多喜欢这一集。
We knew you were in it and we liked you being in it, but it was really fun to rewatch this one because it's just like, it's its own weird little storytelling gimmick and you're great in it.
我们知道你在里面，我们喜欢你在里面，但是重看这个真的很有趣，因为它就像，它有它自己奇怪的讲故事的小花招，而你在里面很棒。
It makes it about character.
这与性格有关。
I mean, it really makes the show about character not about plot because half of the plot isn't actually happening.
我的意思是，这确实让这部剧变得关于角色而不是情节，因为一半的情节实际上并没有发生。
It's just a fantasy, you know, it's just, you know, a dream sequence almost, and, and, and so it's really great and, and I just think it'd be great if there, if somebody else had tried to do that a little bit.
这只是一个幻想，你知道，它只是，你知道，几乎是一个梦境序列，而且，而且，所以它真的很棒，而且我认为如果有的话那就太好了，如果有人尝试这样做一点。
I don't think people did ever.
我认为人们从来没有这样做过。
I don't think any other show So we like doing things where it was like a philosophical symposium on an idea.
我不认为有任何其他节目所以我们喜欢做一些事情，就像一场关于一个想法的哲学研讨会。
This one, it's kind of this idea of karma and anger.
这就是一种业力和愤怒的想法。
And should you continue the chain of screaming or does that need to end somewhere?
你应该继续尖叫还是需要在某个地方结束？
And do you want to live your adult life?
你想过成年人的生活吗？
Is this Jason Segal's character, Marshall is kind of asking himself, wait a second, I want it to be this environmental lawyer.
这是杰森·西格尔的角色吗？马歇尔有点问自己，等一下，我希望是这位环境律师。
And now I've sold my soul to make some money to this corporation and I'm getting screamed at.
现在我为了给这家公司赚点钱而出卖了我的灵魂，却遭到了尖叫。
Do I want an adult life where I can be screamed at and that's okay?
我想要一个可以被人尖叫但没关系的成年生活吗？
And it's just funny like we started off this conversation you saying like I almost didn't believe how nice everyone was on the How I met your mother said it almost seemed like a trick or something I assumed that when you say that what you mean, and I've been on some of these shows too is There's a chain of screaming in Hollywood sometimes you right there are these negative Climates that we've all been in and how much your mother for whatever reason?
有趣的是，就像我们开始这次谈话时，你说的那样，我几乎不相信每个人都对我如何认识你母亲说这几乎看起来像是一个把戏，或者我认为当你说出你的意思时，我也参加过其中一些节目，好莱坞有时会出现一连串的尖叫声，你对，我们都经历过这些负面气候，你的母亲出于某种原因有多少？
And I think Pam Fryman, our director, set this tone.
我认为我们的导演帕姆·弗莱曼（Pam Fryman）定下了这个基调。
I think Carter and I are nice enough fellows.
我认为卡特和我是足够好的伙伴。
We hired writers who were nice.
我们聘请了很好的作家。
We had a real no assholes kind of thing there.
我们那里确实没有混蛋之类的事情。
And it's fairly rare.
而且这种情况相当罕见。
And so when you're coming into that, and it seemed like jarringly nice to you, is that because you felt, do you go in on your guard because you've had enough experiences?
所以当你进入这个领域时，这对你来说似乎非常好，是因为你觉得，你是否因为你已经有足够的经验而保持警惕？
And what do you think of that?
你对此有何看法？
What do you think of those other climates?
您对其他气候有何看法？
And have you been stuck in, anyone, SNL for a while?
你是否已经被《周六夜现场》困住了一段时间了？
there's so much annoying shit that go the part of acting that we like or directing or writing is the super fun part where you're flowing and you're making the thing and you're acting and everything around it and there's so much around it.
有很多烦人的狗屎，我们喜欢的表演部分或者导演或写作是超级有趣的部分，你在流动，你在制作东西，你在表演以及周围的一切，周围有很多东西。
Yes Is not the fun part and the more you do it the more that shit?
是的，这不是有趣的部分，而且你做得越多，就越糟糕吗？
Where's you down?
你在哪儿？
Yes?
是的？
Yeah, and and it's where I see another way I see this is I see old actors who are like I don't want makeup.
是的，这就是我看到的另一种方式，我看到老演员就像我不想化妆一样。
I don't need yet.
我还不需要。
I don't need it It's fine.
我不需要它，没关系。
I said the line and it's like I get it.
我说了这句话，就好像我明白了。
I get it.
我得到它。
I get it I get sick of sitting make up your sick of waiting you're tired of we got to do another take cuz this was wrong That was wrong, but that's the show.
我明白了，我厌倦了坐着化妆，你厌倦了等待，你厌倦了我们必须再拍一次，因为这是错误的，那是错误的，但这就是节目。
That's what it is.
就是这样。
That's it I always when I see it and I've seen a lot of fair amount is I always think Never forget That all that shit is just as legit a part of this job as the part that you like Yeah, it's all the only thing when you do Broadway, I did Broadway And you do have to rehearse and all that and and then you have to do the lighting Which is like a week of just moves must take two steps to your right now stand there.
当我看到它时，我总是这样，我已经看过很多了，我总是想，永远不要忘记，所有这些狗屎都是这个工作的合法部分，就像你喜欢的部分一样，是的，这是你演百老汇时唯一的事情，我演百老汇，你必须排练和所有这些，然后你必须做灯光，这就像一周的动作，必须走两步才能站在那里。
Don't move Go back go back stand there That week, but once the show gets going you're just doing the acting.
别动，回去，回去，站在那里那一周，但一旦演出开始，你就只是在表演。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah Yeah, yeah, it's very satisfying in that, you know, it's just just one take every night, you know One of the great things and the other part that's fun is you work with the audience like you feel them And you go like oh you like this you like that.
是的，是的，是的，这是非常令人满意的，你知道，这只是每天晚上拍摄一次，你知道，最伟大的事情之一，另一个有趣的部分是你和观众一起工作，就像你能感觉到他们一样，你会感觉哦，你喜欢这个，你喜欢那个。
That's where your head is at This is what you're noticing and you work with them, but anyhow the point is I Joined you guys third season I certainly expected people to at least just show up and And sort of, it's a read through, just like, all right, let's go, hey, how's it going?
这就是你的头脑所在，这就是你所注意到的，你和他们一起工作，但无论如何，重点是我加入了你们第三季，我当然希望人们至少会出现，并且有点，这是一个通读，就像，好吧，让我们走，嘿，怎么样？
Did you buy a boat?
你买船了吗？
I didn't boat or something like that.
我没有划船或类似的事情。
I bought one two weeks ago, it's already sinking.
我两周前买了一个，它已经下沉了。
And just, all right, read the thing.
好吧，读一下这个东西。
OK, great.
好的，太好了。
Why don't we show up tomorrow with three?
我们明天为什么不带着三个人一起出现呢？
OK, see you three.
好的，三位见。
I just expected that, you know, we should get this done.
我只是期望，你知道，我们应该完成这件事。
This is a read through, you know.
这是一篇通读，你知道。
And it was not that at all.
但事实并非如此。
It was a very happy encouraging, happy to be there.
这是一个非常令人高兴的鼓励，很高兴能在那里。
I always thought, this must be, now forgive me if I'm wrong, Josh, but Neil and Jason, who had resumes of some length, right?
我一直想，这一定是，如果我错了，请原谅我，乔什，但是尼尔和杰森，他们的简历都有一定的长度，对吗？
When they got the show.
当他们拿到节目的时候。
Neil's true, I mean, Jason had Allison.
尼尔是真的，我的意思是，杰森拥有艾莉森。
Maybe more than Jason.
也许比杰森还多。
Allison more than Jason.
艾莉森比杰森多。
I mean, Jason had freaks and geeks, which at that point was becoming kind of iconic, but.
我的意思是，杰森有怪胎和极客，这在当时已经成为一种标志性的东西，但是。
Right, so I always ascribe it to that person, because it's the experienced person who's the most jaded and who brings in, and who the younger people go like, I don't know how to behave.
是的，所以我总是把它归咎于那个人，因为经验丰富的人是最疲惫的，他会带进来，而年轻人喜欢谁，我不知道如何表现。
I guess he does.
我想他会的。
He's done it, so I guess you've been playing and get mad and get frustrated all the time, because that's how you do this, I don't know.
他已经做到了，所以我猜你一直在玩、生气、沮丧，因为这就是你做这件事的方式，我不知道。
And so that's where that number one on the call sheet or most experienced person really matters a lot because everyone was taking their cue from that person.
因此，这就是电话表上的第一名或最有经验的人真正重要的地方，因为每个人都从那个人那里得到暗示。
And so I thought it was the, I just assumed these experienced people just told everyone, you got to be happy that we're here.
所以我认为这是，我只是假设这些经验丰富的人只是告诉每个人，你必须为我们在这里感到高兴。
We're very lucky that the show worked so well.
我们很幸运，这个节目效果很好。
I don't remember that there was any sort of, I mean, first season, and I had forgotten about this, Craig, but like we used to have breakfast after every, the cast used to have breakfast just down the street, in wherever, Century City, after every table read, we stopped doing it at some point.
我不记得有任何形式的，我的意思是，第一季，我已经忘记了这一点，克雷格，但就像我们过去每次吃早餐一样，演员们过去常常在街上吃早餐，在世纪城的任何地方，在每张桌子读完后，我们在某个时候停止这样做。
But it was really sweet.
但真的很甜蜜。
I think there was a sense, either Kobe and I, I had done like three or four pilots.
我认为有一种感觉，无论是科比还是我，我都做过三四个飞行员。
I'd had every version of Think Happen.
我听过《Think Happen》的每个版本。
I'd never had a hit show.
我从来没有看过热门节目。
Kobe was very new.
科比是个新人。
Ali, Jason, and Neil had more experience, but not, we were all kind of the same age.
阿里、杰森和尼尔有更多的经验，但不是，我们都是同龄人。
I think there was a sense that we knew we had something good going.
我认为我们有一种感觉，我们知道我们正在做一些好事。
And we knew that these scripts were really inventive really funny.
我们知道这些剧本真的很有创意，也很有趣。
We knew that there was really good chemistry among the cast that you don't want to talk about because why would you talk about it?
我们知道演员之间确实有很好的化学反应，但你不想谈论它，因为你为什么要谈论它？
It's just going to kill it.
它只会杀死它。
So I think we just had this quiet sense that all guns were firing and like, we're just going to keep doing this.
所以我认为我们只是有一种安静的感觉，所有的枪都在开火，我们会继续这样做。
And then I think there was a sense like why behave in a way that gets in the way, especially.
然后我认为有一种感觉，特别是为什么要以一种妨碍的方式行事。
And I think that it's, you know, Carter and Craig, they're so humble, they don't take a lot of credit for it, but they were such nice young talented guys in and Pam was such an earth-mama-loving presence.
我认为，你知道，卡特和克雷格，他们非常谦虚，他们并没有因此获得太多荣誉，但他们是非常好的年轻有才华的小伙子，而帕姆是一个热爱地球妈妈的存在。
Big time.
很开心。
That you feel like you've had enough experiences to go, it isn't always this way.
你觉得自己已经有足够的经历了，但事实并非总是如此。
We better bring it, you know?
我们最好把它带来，你知道吗？
This is like...
这就像...
Pam was good at saying, it's not guys.
帕姆很擅长说，这不是男人。
She said that to us every week.
她每周都对我们这么说。
It's not always like this.
情况并不总是这样。
That was when she was reminding us constantly.
那时她不断地提醒我们。
And there's some good situation.
还有一些好的情况。
Some more grizzled crew members who you could see, you could see the chain of screaming that they had lived in until now.
你可以看到更多头发花白的船员，你可以看到他们迄今为止一直生活在的尖叫声中。
And they would say to you, like, you got a good one here.
他们会对你说，比如，你在这里找到了一个很好的人。
Don't fuck this thing up, kid.
别把这件事搞砸了，孩子。
And Carter and I never had much of an interest, Bob, in developing too much outside of how much a mother we really ran it the whole time.
鲍勃，卡特和我从来没有太多兴趣去发展太多超出我们作为母亲一直在运作的东西。
We were contractually obligated to attempt other pilots a few times.
根据合同，我们有义务尝试其他飞行员几次。
And I'm not saying we didn't try, we did.
我并不是说我们没有尝试，我们确实尝试过。
But it's that development hell you're talking about, Bob, that I guess we caught you in at this exact moment.
但鲍勃，你所说的正是开发地狱，我想我们正是在这个时刻抓住了你。
And I guess lucky for us, you were in that moment and were starved to go interact with other humans and not just sit with the script and development hell, but it is a shit feeling to be out there and development hell.
我想我们很幸运，你在那一刻渴望与其他人互动，而不仅仅是坐在剧本和开发地狱里，但在那里和开发地狱真是一种糟糕的感觉。
It really is, you really are dying to just make something.
确实如此，你真的很想做出一些东西。
And we did have an awareness card and I like, we're getting to make 24 episodes a year of this thing we like.
我们确实有一张意识卡，我喜欢，我们每年都会制作 24 集我们喜欢的东西。
We were smart enough, even though we were young to go, let's not, let's not, um, Icarus this up, you know?
我们足够聪明，尽管我们还很年轻，但我们不要，我们不要，嗯，伊卡洛斯这样，你知道吗？
Let's not, let's not fly any closer to the sun than we need to.
不，我们不要飞得比我们需要的更接近太阳。
Let's enjoy the flying part and not fall.
让我们享受飞行的乐趣，不要摔倒。
Well, I think, Craig, and we've talked about this a lot, Bob, like they were 29 years old imagining a 53 year old or whatever, talking to his kids.
嗯，我想，克雷格，鲍勃，我们已经讨论过很多次了，就像他们在 29 岁时想象着 53 岁或其他什么人，与他的孩子们交谈一样。
So they were actually the age of the characters in the present, but they were imagining this older, wiser voice.
所以他们实际上是现在角色的年龄，但他们想象的是这个更老、更明智的声音。
So I always felt like it gave you guys some sense of like perspective and time and like it's one thing to be young, it's another thing to know you're young.
所以我总觉得这给了你们一些视角和时间的感觉，年轻是一回事，知道自己年轻又是另一回事。
Like right?
喜欢吗？
Like those are different things.
就像这些是不同的事情。
We were cosplaying wisdom in some way and we were like, and it did make us think about future selves.
我们以某种方式扮演智慧，这确实让我们思考未来的自己。
And I just have a question for you, Bob.
我有一个问题要问你，鲍勃。
I heard you say the nicest thing on Mike Brabiglia's podcast when he said, who are you envious of in life?
我听到你在迈克·布拉比利亚的播客上说了最好听的一句话，他说，你在生活中羡慕谁？
And you said, anyone who has young kids still.
你说，任何还有小孩的人。
And I basically started almost crying.
我几乎开始哭了。
My son's 19, my daughter's 10.
我儿子19岁，我女儿10岁。
So my daughter's right in that moment where you're like, it's still there.
所以我女儿就在那一刻，你就像，它仍然在那里。
But you know, you can feel that it's not gonna be forever.
但你知道，你可以感觉到这不会是永远的。
And my wife and I, Bob just had a baby seven months ago.
我和我的妻子鲍勃七个月前刚刚生了孩子。
So I'm just at the start of all.
所以我才刚刚开始。
the cutest little chubby cheek seven month old boy.
最可爱的七个月大的胖乎乎的小男孩。
It's awesome, man.
太棒了，伙计。
You lucky.
你很幸运。
I wanted to ask you about parenthood, Bob.
我想问你关于为人父母的事，鲍勃。
So how much a mother is this story?
那么这个故事到底有多少母亲呢？
The framing device is it's this dad in 2030, talking to his two board kids on the couch that are sitting there hearing their dad's long story of ups and downs and oversharing and some wisdom.
故事的框架是，2030 年的这位父亲，正在沙发上与他的两个寄宿孩子交谈，他们坐在那儿听他们的父亲讲述起起伏伏、过度分享和一些智慧的长篇故事。
I'm looking at that couch behind you and it's sort of like that.
我看着你身后的沙发，有点像那样。
It's sort of like this is the dad's like, basically the room you're in, but your kids would be sitting there and you'd be telling them, We had this debate the other day or just discussion like, is do we tell our kids these stories so they won't make mistakes?
这有点像爸爸的样子，基本上就是你所在的房间，但你的孩子会坐在那里，你会告诉他们，我们前几天进行了这场辩论，或者只是讨论，我们是否应该告诉我们的孩子这些故事，这样他们就不会犯错误？
Like we're trying to give them wisdom, don't do this stupid thing.
就像我们试图给他们智慧一样，不要做这种蠢事。
Or is it that you're telling them your mistakes so they feel safe to make mistakes?
或者你告诉他们你的错误，这样他们就可以安全地犯错误？
And you know, does that whole parenting approach of like, I feel like the show, I think someone asked us this, maybe a fan wrote in with that question.
你知道，整个育儿方法是否就像，我觉得这个节目，我想有人问过我们这个问题，也许是一个粉丝写了这个问题。
I think that the dad and how much mother is sharing all of this probably inappropriate material with his children.
我认为父亲和母亲正在与他的孩子们分享所有这些可能不合适的材料。
I think in part to be like, I fucked up a lot and I want you to know that's what happens.
我想部分原因是，我搞砸了很多次，我想让你知道这就是发生的事情。
That's you have to fuck up along the way to kind of become the person you grow up to be.
也就是说，你必须一路努力才能成为你长大后成为的人。
I'm just curious, like, how do you see it with your kids?
我只是很好奇，你对你的孩子怎么看？
When you taught your kids, I do talk like this to my kids, but only I'm very aware that I only get moments to do it.
当你教你的孩子时，我确实对我的孩子们这样说话，但只有我很清楚我只有时间去做。
Like I have to watch for the moment.
就像我必须暂时观察一样。
I can't just go around talking for a half hour every week.
我不能每周花半个小时到处闲聊。
10 kids don't look thrilled about it either, by the way.
顺便说一句，10 个孩子看起来也不对此感到兴奋。
You get two to three times a year and you gotta watch for it where you're, in my case, 25 and 27 year old, might be open to a longer self-revolatory Uh, it's, it's, it's everything.
你每年会有两到三次这样的经历，你必须留意，就我而言，25 岁​​和 27 岁，可能会接受更长的自我革命，呃，它，它，这就是一切。
It's an apology for how I'm fucked up and I, I, I fucked you up.
这是我为我搞砸了而我，我，我搞砸了你而道歉。
Yeah.
是的。
It's an explanation.
这是一个解释。
You have to understand I'm this and I went through this.
你必须明白我就是这样，我经历过这一切。
Yeah.
是的。
It's an apology.
这是一个道歉。
It's a warning.
这是一个警告。
Don't do what I did.
别做我做的事。
And sometimes it's a, it's a comfort that simply says, everyone does some version of this, what you just said.
有时，这是一种安慰，只是说，每个人都会做一些版本的事情，就像你刚才所说的那样。
Yeah.
是的。
You know, and maybe it's some, you know, lecture on how to be, but it's, you know, my son wrote this great TV pilot and we're pursuing it, trying to get it made.
你知道，也许这是一些关于如何做人的讲座，但你知道，我儿子写了这个伟大的电视试播集，我们正在追求它，试图把它拍出来。
It's very unique.
这是非常独特的。
That's awesome.
太棒了。
I didn't know that.
我不知道。
And he was, we have, you know, multiple episodes sketched out and, but he was starting to write the second episode and he was getting really stumped on it and he'd written 60 pages and then The next time I talk to me at four pages And I Saw this moment where I was able to say Look, you know, you did something you established a voice in that first one.
你知道，他是，我们已经勾勒出多集的草图，但是他开始写第二集，他真的被难住了，他写了60页，然后下次我和我谈话时写了四页，我看到了这一刻，我可以说看，你知道，你做了一些你在第一集中建立了声音的事情。
You kind of can't go wrong You can of course, but you can't really because if you wrote it and you liked it.
你不会出错，你当然可以，但你真的不能，因为如果你写了它并且你喜欢它。
That's what we're selling really.
这就是我们真正卖的东西。
Right.
正确的。
So it's not.
所以事实并非如此。
And then I said, you know, how Stephen Wright writes 10 jokes, you know, two of them are the best jokes ever written in history.
然后我说，你知道，斯蒂芬·赖特如何写了 10 个笑话，你知道，其中两个是历史上最好的笑话。
Four of them are goddamn good.
其中四个人都非常好。
Two of them are, could be a little better and two of them aren't that great.
其中两个是，可能会好一点，而其中两个则不是那么好。
Anybody could come up with those.
任何人都可以想出这些。
But he does all 10 because he's got to do a 40 minute show.
但他完成了全部 10 场表演，因为他要表演 40 分钟的表演。
Right.
正确的。
And they're all right.
他们都很好。
And they're all Stephen Wright.
他们都是斯蒂芬·赖特。
They're all Stephen Wright.
That's something great.
那真是太棒了。
They are okay.
他们没事。
Yes.
是的。
So it was a lecture about when you've done something like that, and I can speak from experience of knowing, you know, I mean, I did that feeling, and you're sure you had it with how I met your mother, like, is this any good?
所以这是一个关于你何时做过类似事情的讲座，我可以从知道的经验中讲，你知道，我的意思是，我有那种感觉，你确定你在我遇见你母亲时也有这种感觉，就像，这有什么好处吗？
Is that any good at some point after, you know, 60 episodes, you're like, well, we wrote it.
在 60 集之后的某个时候，你会觉得，好吧，我们写了它，这有什么好处吗？
And we like it.
我们喜欢它。
It's it's it's how I make your mother.
这就是我造就你母亲的方式。
Right.
正确的。
That's that's what it is.
就是这样。
Yeah.
是的。
So it's one better than the other.
所以这是一个比另一个更好的。
Sure.
当然。
But they're all how I met your mother because we came from us.
但它们都是我认识你母亲的方式，因为我们来自我们。
And that's a great feeling that lets you exhale a little bit.
这是一种很棒的感觉，可以让你稍微松口气。
Same as true of acting, you know, actors.
与表演一样，你知道，演员。
I'm you know, whether it's Broadway or anything, you know, you get deep into that thing and some where you're doing that thing of like, should I be doing this?
我是你知道的，无论是百老汇还是其他什么地方，你知道，你深入那件事，在某些地方你正在做类似的事情，我应该这样做吗？
Is this any good?
这有什么好处吗？
And I'm like, look, you have it.
我想，看，你已经拥有了。
You just do.
你就这样做。
And can it be better one night or less better than one night?
住一晚会比住一晚好还是差一点？
Sure, I guess so.
当然，我想是这样。
But you're doing it.
但你正在这样做。
You established it.
你建立了它。
You're there.
你就在那里。
You know, just let go of that major doubt and carry out.
你知道，只要放下那个重大疑虑并执行即可。
But that was an opportunity.
但这是一个机会。
I was obviously talking about writing, But you know, your kids, I think I had a conversation that's more akin to how I met your mother, you know, episode story with my daughter a few weeks ago.
我显然是在谈论写作，但是你知道，你的孩子们，我想我的谈话更像是我几周前与我女儿见面的情节故事。
And it was just one of those things where you realize like, oh, I got a moment, she's listening, she's really listening, she really wants.
这只是你意识到的事情之一，哦，我有一瞬间，她在听，她真的在听，她真的想要。
I love your wisdom in choosing those moments, knowing that they're not always there, but recognizing when they are.
我喜欢你选择这些时刻的智慧，知道它们并不总是存在，但在它们存在时能够识别出来。
That's the moment, yeah.
就是那个时刻，是的。
And it's, it's, I'd say I've gotten much better at it, but I'm not naturally good at it because I, my name, my last name is Oden Kirk.
我想说我在这方面做得更好了，但我天生并不擅长，因为我，我的名字，我的姓氏是奥登·柯克。
And we have a, we have a genetic, um, deep predisposition to lecturing people.
我们有一种遗传性的、嗯、很深的说教倾向。
It's so stupid.
真是太蠢了。
All my brothers do it.
我所有的兄弟都这样做。
It's why you were perfect as Arthur.
这就是为什么你作为亚瑟是完美的。
there.
那里。
What the fuck is that?
那是什么鬼？
It's that Jordan Peterson, it's some like whatever, Jordan Peterson gene where you think that everybody wants to hear you fucking go on and on, how they should live their lives.
这就是乔丹·彼得森，有点像乔丹·彼得森的基因，你认为每个人都想听你他妈的继续说下去，他们应该如何生活。
Yeah.
是的。
You know, I don't know if you know this, Ira Glass quote where he talks about, it's It's really hard to be a young artist because your taste is better than your abilities and that you have to keep making stuff to where your actual stuff you're making reaches what you know is good.
你知道，我不知道你是否知道这一点，艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）引用他的话说，成为一名年轻艺术家真的很难，因为你的品味比你的能力更好，你必须不断地制作东西，直到你正在制作的东西达到你所知道的好水平。
And most people give up before they get those aligned.
大多数人在协调一致之前就放弃了。
And I talked to him years ago and I mentioned that quote and he said, you know, I said that so offhandedly one time to a reporter.
几年前我和他谈过，我提到了这句话，他说，你知道，有一次我对记者这么说过。
And it's literally the most quoted thing I've ever said.
这实际上是我说过的被引用最多的一句话。
It's just like this viral, that's what this is.
就像病毒一样，就是这样。
is Burbiglia clipped with you, right?
布尔比利亚和你在一起吗？
It is, and I, of course I must tell you, I was utterly being honest, I obviously didn't know what question he was gonna ask me, and I, you know, when you do these deep interviews like Burbiglia or the New York Times I just did, there's so many interviews you do.
是的，我当然必须告诉你，我完全诚实，我显然不知道他会问我什么问题，而且我，你知道，当你像布尔比利亚或我刚刚做过的《纽约时报》那样进行深度采访时，你会做很多采访。
Right, there's so many interviews you do that are just promotional, right?
是的，你做的很多采访只是为了宣传，对吧？
And- Yeah, yeah.
而且-是的，是的。
Early on, if you're paying attention, you learn that these interviews don't want you to be honest.
早期，如果你注意的话，你就会发现这些采访并不希望你诚实。
Like, if you start being honest, they look at you like, what's going on?
就像，如果你开始诚实，他们就会看着你，好像发生了什么事？
I just want you to say, I just want you to say, the movie is great.
我只想你说，我只想你说，这部电影很棒。
We had so much fun doing that, you're going to have fun watching it.
我们这样做很有趣，你也会很开心地观看它。
Just tell me that, you know, don't say, uh, I saw that you were in the desert when you shot that.
只要告诉我，你知道，不要说，呃，当你开枪时我看到你在沙漠里。
Was that hot?
那热吗？
I don't want to hear like, no, it was fine.
我不想听到这样的话，不，很好。
It was, you know, yeah, I want to hear like, Oh, God, it was so hot.
你知道，是的，我想听到这样的话，哦，上帝，太热了。
The sun is so bright in the desert.
沙漠里的阳光是那么的耀眼。
Like I just tell me what's kind of obvious and yeah.
就像我只是告诉我什么是显而易见的，是的。
And then you get into these other interviews, this other level, which is you ask yourself, how am I going to do this and not look like an asshole and not say something wrong and I'm going to just take my time and I'm going to be honest.
然后你进入其他面试，这个另一个层面，你问自己，我要怎么做，才不会看起来像个混蛋，也不会说错话，我会慢慢来，我会诚实。
I'm gonna just be honest.
我会说实话。
And then when I left that Brabiglia interview, I got and they sent a car for me, which was totally unnecessary.
然后当我离开布拉比利亚采访时，他们给我派了一辆车，这是完全没有必要的。
But I got in the car and I'm like, the thing I said about being jealous of people with kids at home, that they're not gonna use that.
但我上了车，我就想，我说过嫉妒家里有孩子的人，他们不会使用这个。
That's just, I thought, that's way too depressing.
只是，我想，这太令人沮丧了。
And I thought it's depressing.
我认为这很令人沮丧。
Well, it wasn't and people liked it.
嗯，事实并非如此，人们喜欢它。
I thought what I thought was depressing about it was we all see people who've had long careers oftentimes in LA We see them at the grocery store and they have where I saw you I saw you with the gelsons a couple years ago I don't know if you're sure But yeah, and they have shitty shitty clothes on and dirty hat and and you some part of you is like Are they?
我觉得令人沮丧的是，我们经常在洛杉矶看到那些有着长期职业生涯的人，我们在杂货店看到他们，他们就在我见过你的地方，几年前我看到你和凝胶森，我不知道你是否确定，但是，是的，他们穿着破烂的衣服，戴着肮脏的帽子，而你的某些部分就像他们是吗？
Did they not make any money at all?
难道他们根本就没有赚到钱吗？
They never renegotiate.
他们从不重新谈判。
You know, the three stooges, I heard a story, what's they never renegotiated.
你知道，三个傀儡，我听过一个故事，他们从未重新谈判过什么。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
I mean, they were children of the depression, right?
我的意思是，他们是大萧条时期的孩子，对吗？
So they got this contract to do these shorts and they just were so afraid of ever asking for a penny more that they never renegotiated.
所以他们拿到了制作这些短裤的合同，但他们只是害怕再多要一分钱，所以他们从未重新谈判。
Like you assholes, you know, and come on.
就像你们这些混蛋一样，你知道，来吧。
They should have pretended to be the three most powerful Hollywood agents, and that would have hurt death.
他们应该假装自己是好莱坞最有权势的三位特工，那样会伤人的。
So my point is simply that that's sad that this guy who's had success in his career and has kids and now they're grown.
所以我的观点很简单，这个在职业生涯中取得成功并有孩子的人现在他们已经长大了，这是令人悲伤的。
And I think he has enough money to live pretty well and people respect him like he envies something that he cannot have back.
我认为他有足够的钱过上很好的生活，人们尊重他，就像他羡慕一些他无法收回的东西一样。
I don't know.
我不知道。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, I guess I could.
嗯，我想我可以。
I'd have to divorce my wife and marry my assistant, but I don't have an assistant.
我必须与我的妻子离婚并与我的助理结婚，但我没有助理。
I think that where it went, kind of viral the way it did, like I talked like three separate dad friends sent me that clip, like it landed on dads, I think, because there's something about, you know, showbiz is insane and it makes you unhappy in totally different ways no matter what stage you're at.
我认为它的传播方式就像病毒一样，就像我说的那样，就像三个不同的爸爸朋友发给我那个剪辑一样，就像它落在爸爸们身上一样，我想，因为有一些东西，你知道，演艺圈很疯狂，无论你处于哪个阶段，它都会以完全不同的方式让你不开心。
It's like there's always a new way to be unhappy and to think you're not doing great and there's new, and I think in some ways the expectation is you ask an actor like who are you jealous of and it's like Tom Cruise, like they want you to say some person, but what you were really saying was like the most special time of your life is when you have something in front of that needs you to keep it alive, and that you know what your mission on Earth is.
好像总有一种新的方式让你不快乐，觉得自己做得不好，但有新的东西，我认为在某些方面，人们的期望是你问一个演员，比如你嫉妒谁，就像汤姆·克鲁斯，他们想让你说某个人，但你真正说的是你生命中最特别的时刻，就是当你面前有一些东西需要你让它活下去，你知道你在地球上的使命是什么。
Like, that's when I found so moving about it, was it was like, and it's very kind of in the world of how I met your mother, that this kind of like, Ted is trying to love his kids by telling these stories.
就像，就在那时，我发现这件事非常感人，就好像，在我遇见你母亲的世界里，就像是，特德试图通过讲述这些故事来爱他的孩子们。
He's trying to love them, he's trying to teach them, and he's also asking for their love and approval back in certain ways, but I just wanna commend you for, I know that that quote is gonna be around for a while, but yeah.
他试图爱他们，他试图教导他们，他也在以某些方式请求他们的爱和认可，但我只是想赞扬你，我知道这句话会流传一段时间，但是是的。
No, but those are the things that people really I think makes them sit up and pay attention is when honesty cuts through the noise Yeah, I think you're right I think it's a good way if you ever find yourself in those interviews and This is sort of one of them, but the point is you know It's a longer interview and you're talking to people your respect and they're not they don't they don't want those canned answers that you know the the the go-to is just think honestly about the question and see if you can say something clearer clearly and a straightforward way.
不，但这些是人们真正让他们坐起来并注意的事情，当诚实消除噪音时是的，我认为你是对的，如果你发现自己在这些采访中，这是一个好方法，这就是其中之一，但重点是你知道这是一个较长的采访，你正在与你尊敬的人交谈，他们不是他们不想要那些你知道的罐装答案，最重要的是诚实地思考问题看看你是否能说得更清楚、更直接。
You know I had so many dads tell me they're in the middle of it right now.
你知道有很多爸爸告诉我他们现在正处于困境之中。
They have a two-year-old and a five-year-old and you know it's hard.
他们有一个两岁和一个五岁的孩子，你知道这很难。
I mean it is.
我的意思是确实如此。
You get so my neighbors have a little guy who he's like our practice grandchild.
你知道我的邻居有一个小家伙，他就像我们练习的孙子。
He's such a great guy and he has this virus that little kids get and he's so upset and I just saw the dad this morning we were both walking our dogs and I went there yesterday to say hi to him and they like he has this thing I'm like okay I will come in you know cuz I don't want to get back and they had the worst night of their lives and those nights and And it's like, do you have two kids or three?
他是一个很棒的人，他感染了小孩子感染的病毒，他非常沮丧，我今天早上刚看到他爸爸，我们都在遛狗，我昨天去那里向他打招呼，他们喜欢他有这种东西，我想好吧，我会进来你知道的，因为我不想回来，他们度过了一生中最糟糕的一晚，那些夜晚，就像，你有两个孩子还是三个孩子？
I mean, come on, those moments are like brutal.
我的意思是，来吧，那些时刻就像残酷的。
So I've had a number of parents who are younger say, I was glad to hear somebody say that and remind me that I should remember that perspective.
所以我有很多年轻的父母说，我很高兴听到有人这么说，并提醒我应该记住这个观点。
Oh, Bob, that's how I took it, honestly.
哦，鲍勃，老实说，我就是这么认为的。
It was the opposite of sad to me because it was like, here's this guy that is very successful and artistic successful and respected.
对我来说，这与悲伤相反，因为这就像，这个人非常成功，在艺术上取得了成功并受到尊重。
And he, he, he missed it.
而他，他，他错过了。
It's none of that has, has, you served at the bigger joy of your life, which was, I loved you said, you knew what you were doing every day of your life.
这一切都没有，你为你的生活带来了更大的快乐，那就是，我爱你说的，你知道你生命中的每一天都在做什么。
You knew what your job was.
你知道你的工作是什么。
And I think that's, we were talking about development hell earlier.
我认为我们之前讨论过开发地狱。
And I think part of what was nice about how much a mother is we knew where we were going for a decade.
我认为，作为一个母亲，我们知道这十年我们要去哪里，这是一件好事。
And that is more akin to a family and parenting.
这更类似于家庭和养育子女。
You know what you're doing every day for a decade when you're with those children and you're just attuned to them.
当你和这些孩子们在一起时，你知道十年来你每天在做什么，并且你只是适应他们。
You're clearly a very good and loving dad, like that you want that job.
你显然是一个非常好的、慈爱的父亲，所以你想要这份工作。
You wanted that job, you knew what that job was when you had it, and you miss it now.
你想要那份工作，当你拥有那份工作时你知道那份工作是什么，但现在你却怀念它。
And I honestly felt like when I saw that clip, I was like looking at my phone on the weekend or something, probably my daughter was in the other room.
老实说，当我看到那个剪辑时，我感觉就像在周末看手机或其他什么，可能我女儿在另一个房间。
I put down my phone and went and hung out with my daughter, like, what are you drawing?
我放下手机，去和女儿一起出去玩，比如，你在画什么？
What are you doing?
你在干什么？
I was like, just like, welcome me up.
我就像，就像，欢迎我。
And I was like, remember, don't miss these moments.
我当时想，记住，不要错过这些时刻。
So thank you for that, honestly.
所以说实话，谢谢你。
And the thing is, my kids are at an age where everyone talks about your college age, like they don't want me around like my kids are an age where they like they are adults like you want to say hey do you remember when you were a kid remember who I remember I was a parent do you remember that because I don't I don't think you remember it at all it was actually a long time you were there you were there like they are at that they're are so far into adulthood now, their sense of self and their self-responsibility towards themselves in the world that you really go like, wow, that's just so long gone.
事情是这样的，我的孩子们正处在一个每个人都在谈论你的大学年龄的年龄，就像他们不希望我在身边一样，就像我的孩子们是一个他们喜欢自己是成年人的年龄，就像你想说的那样，嘿，你还记得当你还是个孩子的时候，还记得我是谁吗？在这个世界上对自己负责，你真的会想，哇，那已经过去了。
And almost like it didn't happen.
几乎就好像这件事没有发生一样。
But I know it did.
但我知道确实如此。
The other thing I'll say is I was the second oldest of seven.
我要说的另一件事是我是七个孩子中第二大的。
And so I was very entertained and enjoyed my younger brothers and sisters.
所以我很开心，也很喜欢我的弟弟妹妹们。
And we're all still very close.
我们仍然非常亲密。
And I knew when we had kids like this is going to be fun.
我知道当我们有了这样的孩子时会很有趣。
I knew what kids were like.
我知道孩子们是什么样的。
So I already, I wasn't, I was a little scared and there's still a lot to learn, but I wasn't completely, I mean, I knew how to change a diaper.
所以我已经，我不是，我有点害怕，还有很多东西要学，但我并不完全，我的意思是，我知道如何换尿布。
You know, I mean, I was 14 when my youngest sister was born.
你知道，我的意思是，我最小的妹妹出生时我才 14 岁。
And so I wasn't like, I was like, this can be great.
所以我不喜欢，我喜欢，这可能很棒。
I love this.
我喜欢这个。
And I, and I, I'm not saying I didn't lose my shit.
我，我，我并不是说我没有失去我的狗屎。
Not I don't much.
不是我不多。
But I, um, my bigger problem was, and this is a problem I've always had.
但我，嗯，我更大的问题是，这是我一直面临的问题。
And this is probably why I'm in drama doing better as a drama actor than as a comedy which is that, when I even sort of look angry, I look really angry.
这可能就是为什么我在戏剧中作为一名戏剧演员比作为一名喜剧演员做得更好，因为当我看起来有点生气时，我看起来真的很生气。
I look really angry.
我看起来真的很生气。
Is that another Odin Kirk-ism?
这是另一种奥丁·柯克主义吗？
Is that another genetic Odin Kirk-ism?
这是另一种遗传的奥丁·柯克主义吗？
It is, it is, my dad is that way.
是是是，我爸就是这样。
Yeah, I've read your book and you talk about that and your book very honestly.
是的，我读过你的书，你非常诚实地谈论了这一点和你的书。
Well, you know what I noticed watching you play Arthur, I was like, when you would get angry, you'd never wink and are not like, I'm not like this guy.
好吧，你知道我在看你扮演亚瑟时注意到了什么，我当时想，当你生气时，你永远不会眨眼，也不会，我不像这个人。
Like, you really seem like you're really angry, but I also never turned on you.
就像，你看起来真的很生气，但我也从来没有对你生气过。
Like I never was like, that guy seems like a jerk.
就像我从来没有那样，那家伙看起来像个混蛋。
Like I'm just delighting in your anger somehow.
就像我只是以某种方式享受你的愤怒一样。
That's the thing, Bob.
就是这样，鲍勃。
I think everything you do, and this is why I was not surprised that you made the leap to drama and now to action.
我认为你所做的一切，这就是为什么我对你从戏剧到行动的飞跃并不感到惊讶。
I believe you in everything you do, and I always see like that warmth and goodness in your eyes and every year for every role you're in.
我相信你所做的一切，每年你扮演的每一个角色，我总是在你眼中看到温暖和善良。
I mean, I've talked about this before, but I do think while I, in some ways I've found my place place in this lane, you know, and it feels more impactful, my presence in this specific lane.
我的意思是，我之前已经谈过这一点，但我确实认为，虽然我在某些方面找到了自己在这条车道上的位置，但我在这条特定车道上的存在感觉更有影响力。
I wanted to do comedy, and I wanted to be better.
我想演喜剧，我想做得更好。
And I knew that I did fine, and I knew that sometimes I was very funny, but that, you know, a lot of the people around me were a lot more fun to watch.
我知道我做得很好，我知道有时我很有趣，但是，你知道，我周围的很多人看起来更有趣。
They just were.
他们只是。
And I was like, Oh, well, I mean, I still loved writing it.
我当时想，哦，好吧，我是说，我仍然喜欢写它。
So I think it's what I love.
所以我想这就是我所爱的。
And but without a doubt, I knew that as a young man, I knew like, I like doing this, but these other people around me are way, way more fun to watch than me.
但毫无疑问，我知道作为一个年轻人，我知道，我喜欢这样做，但我周围的其他人比我更有趣。
And that's just the way it is.
事情就是这样。
But those people had to be so fucking funny to out do you're talking about like writing a sketch that you were good in, but then Chris Farley gets it.
但那些人必须太他妈的有趣了，才能像你所说的那样写出你擅长的草图，然后克里斯·法利就明白了。
And it's like, all right, that's Farley, that's that's tough competition.
好吧，这就是法利，这就是激烈的竞争。
Yeah, but just to give you perspective.
是的，但只是为了给你一个视角。
It's hard being Scotty Pippin, Bob.
做斯科蒂·皮平很难，鲍勃。
Yeah, I know.
是的，我知道。
That's right.
这是正确的。
I did want to say Bob, one more thing from your David Marquesi interview in the New York Times, which I listened to and really loved.
我确实想说鲍勃，这是《纽约时报》大卫·马奎西采访中的另一件事，我听了并且非常喜欢。
Me too.
我也是。
You said something that I thought was so smart and so, like, also probably not what he was expecting.
你说了一些我认为很聪明的话，但也可能不是他所期待的。
But he said, like, you've worked with these cult hero comedy people.
但他说，就像，你和这些邪教英雄喜剧人一起工作过。
And then you've worked with, you know, Will Ferrell and all these other people.
然后你就和威尔·法瑞尔以及所有其他人一起工作过。
So what do you think stopped those people from becoming that and I remember you said well I don't think they wanted to become that and I just remember being like I just remember feeling like fuck Yeah, sorry to craig's mom and my mother-in-law doesn't like me to swear But like I thought everyone assumes that everyone wants to be on Mount Rushmore or be the highest paid movie star in the world And it's simply not true like sometimes people are like I'm out This I'm not enjoying this.
那么你认为是什么阻止了那些人成为那样，我记得你说得好，我不认为他们想成为那样，我只记得就像我只记得感觉像操是的，对不起克雷格的妈妈，我的岳母不喜欢我发誓但就像我以为每个人都假设每个人都想登上拉什莫尔山或成为世界上收入最高的电影明星这根本不是真的，有时人们就像我不喜欢这样。
I don't like being recognized everywhere.
我不喜欢到处都被认出来。
I go I'd rather move to the country I think people don't consider that there's so much more going and a lot of the people that Go that are like I'm gonna be the biggest movie star in the world I think there's psychotic in a way like I think there's their brains are a little bit broken right there It's like billionaires.
我去，我宁愿搬到这个国家，我认为人们不认为还有那么多的事情要做，很多人都认为我将成为世界上最大的电影明星，我认为他们的大脑在某种程度上有点精神病，就像亿万富翁一样。
I can't have enough money Absolutely.
我的钱绝对不够。
I listen.
我听着。
This is something What was it Andy Rudy was?
这是安迪·鲁迪是什么？
Am I not remembering that correctly?
我没记错吗？
Do you know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
I don't remember that.
我不记得了。
I don't remember that It was anti-rudy and he was bitching about Kurt Cobain not being happy being recognized or being famous or whatever beaks.
我不记得那是反鲁迪的，他抱怨库尔特·科本不高兴被认可或出名或其他什么。
Oh yeah, as if that should have made him happy.
哦，是的，好像这应该让他高兴。
Yeah, like, well, come on, you understand that these are all different things.
是的，好吧，来吧，你明白这些都是不同的事情。
Yeah.
是的。
Doing what you do for a living and getting proficient at it so that you're proud of yourself.
做你所从事的工作并精通它，这样你就会为自己感到自豪。
Having people recognize that to a level that you can pay your bills with.
让人们认识到这一点，达到你可以支付账单的水平。
Having people recognize that to a degree that you can more than pay your bills with.
让人们认识到这一点，您不仅可以用它来支付账单。
Having people recognize that to where you can more than pay your bills and everyone recognizes you wherever you go.
让人们认识到您不仅可以支付账单，而且无论您走到哪里，每个人都会认出您。
And then even like another level that's even higher of of like impossible to avoid and being messianic, like people in the case of Kurt Cobain or someone like that, they're like, you're almost a magical creature from another dimension.
然后甚至像另一个更高的水平，就像无法避免和弥赛亚一样，就像库尔特·柯本或类似的人那样，他们就像，你几乎是来自另一个维度的神奇生物。
Those are all different levels.
这些都是不同级别的。
And when we do what we do, which is a public facing job, the assumption is like, well, do you want everyone to like you, right?
当我们做我们所做的事情时，这是一项面向公众的工作，我们的假设是，好吧，你希望每个人都喜欢你，对吗？
You want everyone to love you and know your stuff and appreciate you and celebrate you, right?
你希望每个人都爱你、了解你的东西、欣赏你、庆祝你，对吗？
That's what you're in.
这就是你所处的情况。
And more is always better, more is always better, right?
更多总是更好，更多总是更好，对吧？
I mean, come on, just do the math, it's easy.
我的意思是，来吧，做一下数学，这很容易。
Well, that's, come on, that is not true.
好吧，那是，得了吧，那不是真的。
Yeah.
是的。
You start to play, you, or whatever you do, you want to make your friends laugh, you're happy other people like it, you want to have a career in it, You can't believe you're making enough money to pay to go to a restaurant with it, then you like, I think I should want more.
你开始玩，你，或者无论你做什么，你想让你的朋友笑，你很高兴其他人喜欢它，你想在其中拥有一份职业，你不敢相信你赚了足够的钱来用它去餐馆，然后你喜欢，我想我应该想要更多。
And the person going through this, they can't do that math right away.
而经历过这一切的人，他们无法立即进行数学计算。
They might think, oh, I think it'd be great if everyone smiled at me and liked me and wanted my picture with math.
他们可能会想，哦，我想如果每个人都对我微笑，喜欢我，想要我的数学照片，那就太好了。
They could be great.
他们可以很棒。
I don't know until it happens.
我不知道，直到它发生。
I don't know what it's like to do that and live in that world.
我不知道这样做并生活在那个世界里是什么感觉。
So yeah, I think it's weird that it shouldn't be so weird to do the math on that, that these are different experiences of life and that it's true that we see Josh and Craig, I'm sure you can name people who you can say they stepped off the train and they stepped back and we did that very consciously.
所以，是的，我认为这很奇怪，对此进行数学计算不应该那么奇怪，这些是不同的生活经历，我们确实看到乔什和克雷格，我相信你可以说出一些人的名字，你可以说他们下了火车，他们后退了，我们非常有意识地做到了这一点。
And it wasn't a failure or a loss for them.
这对他们来说并不是失败或损失。
It was actually their victory.
这实际上是他们的胜利。
That was their victory to do that, not their setback.
这是他们做到这一点的胜利，而不是他们的挫折。
You sounded a little nostalgic in that interview Bob for the cool weirdo with the Mr. Show tattoo reference on their arm and that was how you would recognize you in the gelsons instead of every other person.
在那次采访中，你听起来有点怀旧，鲍勃，对手臂上有 Mr. Show 纹身的酷怪人，这就是你在格尔森中认出你而不是其他人的方式。
Yeah, I love when you said you walk into any room and you could point to your three fans.
是的，我喜欢你说你走进任何一个房间，你都可以指着你的三个粉丝。
Like you knew you'd have a sense of who they were.
就像你知道你知道他们是谁一样。
I know.
我知道。
And then you're like, that's the right amount of fame.
然后你会想，这就是适当的名气。
Like if Kurt Komen was famous enough for fucking Andy Rooney to know who he was, that's too famous.
就像科特·科曼（Kurt Komen）因操安迪·鲁尼（Andy Rooney）而出名到知道他是谁一样，那就太出名了。
Andy Rooney is not know who Kurt Komen is.
安迪·鲁尼不知道库尔特·科曼是谁。
Yeah.
是的。
Bob, I feel like I feel like we've taken up too much of your time, but we love you so much.
鲍勃，我觉得我们占用了你太多的时间，但我们非常爱你。
Thank you for doing this.
谢谢你这样做。
This was a treat to talk to you.
能和你说话真是一种享受。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Congratulations on making the show that you made that has resonated for so long with so many people and by the way a couple times a year Artillery Arthur is that one of the Bob you get stopped and that's one of the that's the funny thing about you you can be recognized for so many different things I am honored that in the in the very small percentage of that pie chart very small is Artillery Arthur well it's true and thank you I am How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas, and it's presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
恭喜你制作了这个节目，长期以来引起了很多人的共鸣，顺便说一句，一年几次《大炮亚瑟》是你被阻止的鲍勃之一，这就是你的有趣之处之一，你可以因为很多不同的事情而被认可，我很荣幸，在饼图的很小一部分中，非常小的就是《大炮亚瑟》，这是真的，谢谢你，我是《我们是如何造就你母亲的》的主持人和执行制作人乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 和克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas)，由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 呈现和发行。
The show is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey, and the show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev.
该节目还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制作人，由我亚历克·列夫制作和编辑。
Our co-producer is Doug Matica.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, a point of blue studios, and our Gen Z Masters are digital content producer Emily Blumberg, an associate producer, Katherine Grove.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Alex Reeves，他是 blue studio 的一员，我们的 Z 世代大师是数字内容制作人 Emily Blumberg，副制作人 Katherine Grove。
Artwork by John Morrow Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
约翰·莫罗 (John Morrow) 的艺术作品 请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评价和评论该节目。
It really does help to spread the word.
它确实有助于传播信息。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《New York City》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Sam Theobold and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢 Sam Theobold 和 Elliot Connors。
Go to HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的 Muse Letters，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas's debut novel, That's Not How It Happened, Wherever Books Are Sold, and read his other published writing at CraigThomasRider.com and you could subscribe to my own dead father's society on Substack.
订购克雷格·托马斯的处女作《事情不是这样发生的》、《无论书在哪里》，并在 CraigThomasRider.com 上阅读他出版的其他作品，您还可以在 Substack 上订阅我已故父亲的社团。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise funds for congenital heart disease research.
要了解您如何做出改变，这展示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“Make a Difference”选项卡。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。
Fox City.
狐狸城。